انا اعتقد جزء كبير من هذا التواصل هي
مهارات موجوده عند الانسان قبل حتى
الارتباط لكن في ذات الوقت هذا الشيء ما
هو سهل للاشخاص اللي اساسا عندهم اشكاليه
في التواصل مع كل الناس مو فقط مع زوجهم
انه هذا الاكثر للاسف يحاسب انه هم اساسا
عندهم اشكاليات تواصل واستمرت في علاقتهم
الزوجيه وبانت في الزواج لان الزواج هو
اكثر علاقه تحتاج تواصل انا اول شيء من
الاشياء اللي بتعلمني جدا انه الناس يصلوا
الى البحث عن مختص في اصعب واحلك اللحظات
بعد ما ارتفعت المشاعر
كيف اقولها اصبحت الماء مره العلاقه صار
فيها اشياء جارحه وللاسف هذا يؤدي الى انه
زي انت ما قلت كثير من العلاقات سواء
انتهت وكانت النهايه هي الخيار الغير
مرغوب فيه او استمرتك للاستمرار يمكن مصدر
اضافي للالم ما بينهم خاضع بشكل كبير هذا
الشيء لتاخر في جوده التواصل ما بين
الطرفين ما ودي ازعج الطرف الاخر
بالتفاصيل فكيف اتواصل بدون ما اكون كريه
اصدقاء مربع الرائعين السلام عليكم كان
حاتم النجار وهذا مربع من ثمانيه الزواج
جزء مهم من حياتنا سواء كنت الان انت
متزوج او ستتزوج فالافكار حول العلاقات
والزواج جزء لا يتجزا من حياتنا جميعا
ولكن في تغييرات اقتصاديه اجتماعيه ضخمه
يعيشها العالم كامل ونعيشها نحن ايضا
بطبيعه الحال النماذج اختلفت نموذج ابائنا
واجدادنا اللي هو الاحادي للرجل هو سيد
المنزل والرجل هو اللي يصرف الرجل هو اللي
يعمل ويخرج من البيت ويرجع يبغى يشوف
البيت نظيف ومرتب وبين النموذج الحالي
الغربي الجديد اللي قاعد يجينا ما ندري
المشكله ما في ارقام ودراسات يعني دقيقه
بس نقدر اتوقع نتفق انه موجود بيننا شفنا
متزوجين عندهم راتب هذا يصرف وهذا يصرف
هذا النموذجين عجيب ايش الافضل هل فيه صح
وغلط هل نتناقش كل واحد يتناقش مع الزوجه
المستقبل في الخطبه في الملكه كيف نعرف ما
هو النموذج الافضل والامثل لنا ما هي عيوب
النماذج المختلفه وما هي فوائدها وهل يمكن
اصلا انه نعيش على النموذج الاول في هذا
العصر اللي اختلف فيه الاقتصاد والفرص
العمل وكل الاشياء تغيرت وما هو اثر ذلك
على الاسر
والابناء والمستقبل في الزواج طلاق هل
يتاثر كل ما تحسن التشريع في حقوق المراه
هل المراه صار عندها فرصه انها تعمل
وحقوقها اصلا في التشريع صارت افضل تكثر
حالات الطلاق وان كان هذا صحيح فهل هو سيء
اصلا جلست انا دكتور عبد الله غازي طبيب
متخصص في العلاج الاسري والزوجي وتناقشنا
في هذه المواضيع المختلفه انا دوري في هذا
اللقاء ما كان محاور محايد وساكت كان عندي
رايه وكنت احاول اني اتناقص مع دكتور عبد
الله ممثلا مو رائحاتهم الشخصي ممثل الراي
هذا الفريق خلينا نقول لانه يعني في
النهايه راي مو رايي انا لحالي يعني في
النهايه اشعر ان المجتمع منقسم فعلا بين
حاتم ورا عبد الله فكان في نقاش وكان في
تبادل الاطراف الحديث بشكل ودي وجميل
دكتور عبد الله شخصيا اعرفه من سنوات
ومن اكثر الاشخاص اللي بيننا احترموا
متبادل برغم اختلافات الكبيره وهذا الشيء
يعجبني جدا فيه واحبه واحترمه واتمنى لو
كان المزيد من الاشخاص فعلا يحترمون بعضهم
برغم الاختلافات لان اللقاءات جميله مثل
هذه يمكن ان تحدث اتمنى انه يعجبكم هذا
اللقاء استمتعوا اهلا وسهلا اهلا بك حياك
الله اكثر شخص اختلف معاه جذريا بس بين
احترام متبادل انت الله ما اعرف هذه مدحه
ولا مدمه مدرية هذا الواقع بس هو حقيقي
فعلا عمري ما شفت منك الا الاحترام والله
ليه صعب احس انه مو صعب لا مو صعب
هو بس المطالف بعض كناس انا احس بكثير من
العداء الافتراضي خصوصا لانه انا حتى ما
تقابلنا كثير على هذا الواقع كم مره مرتين
ثلاثه لكن في ناس كثير وممكن يكون عندهم
اداء افتراضي مع ناس ما قبلهم اساسا في
حياتهم مبني على التصورات احنا خلقنا شخص
في مخنا وحطيناه عليه قولبناه بقالب كامل
ونسينا ان هو ترى انسان له الحق فراى
مختلفه عننا
عليها لو الحق
قبل كم يوم كنت في الدي ام في الرسائل
الخاصه بيني وبينك
ولقيت شيرين من زمان واتذكرت ليش احترمك
انا كنت كاتب تغريد عن موضوع معين من
المواضيع اللي
تسبب انا عارف فانت كنت تبغى تعلق على
الموضوع بانك تطرح سؤال الجمهورك فكنت
تبغى تسوي كود تويت وتقول جمهوري ايش
رايكم في كلام حاتم
[موسيقى]
لو قعدت تغريد هذا التغريده وكتبت هذا
التعليق هل بيضايقك هذا الشيء وانك فتحه
يعني تغريده في تويتر يمديك تاخدها
بس اشعر انك كنت تبغى تقول لي ترى حاتم
ابغى اسوي هذه الحركه بس مو عشان
جمهوري يهاجمك وكذا لانه بس ابغى اثر
النقاش بالضبط وهو شايل هم من جمهور اللي
يقرا لتغريداتي يشن هجوم عليك فكنت ابغى
رايك في هل انت اساسا هذا الشيء مرتاح له
ما انت مرتاح لو موافق عليها غير الكلام
اتكلم بشكل مبني للمجهول و سويت زي كذا
شوف انا اعيد ان وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ممكن يكون فيها تحسب وفيها خندقه وفيها
هجوم كاسح يؤثر على الاشخاص اللي موجودين
قدامك فانا قررت انه عمري ان شاء الله
وذكروني مستقبلا عمري ان شاء الله ما اكون
جزء من هذا التخندق واذا في اي شيء شكيته
ممكن يسوي هذا الشيء هاحاول اني استاذن
موقف محترم جدا الله يسعدك بس كنت اكلم
محارب انا بني ادم خبير انت انتظر
المضاربه
كلنا عاد بالجيوش المتعاكسه يعني الموضوع
اللي متحمس نتكلم عنه اليوم
احس انه دائما موجود في حياه كل احد
ومتحمس اسولف عنه مع واحد من الفريق
المعاكس يمكن مقابل المقابل المقابل
المقابل لانه اشعر دائما انه الفرق
المقابله اللي يجمعهم اكثر من يفرقهم انه
نحن مره مره مختلفين ويمكن هو مو رائحتهم
قبل عبد الله هو راي فعلا مجموعات ضخمه
يعني في النهايه مو حاتم هو قائد الفريق
انا متبني نظره باخذها من المجموعه
الكامله وممكن
برضه نفس الشيء انت يعني تخيل اتكلم عن
ادوار التوجيه
متى اول مره بدات تتعاطى مع هذا المفهوم
انا اعتقد انه هو طبعا بدانا نتعاطى مع
هذا المفهوم مبكرا في حياتنا كلنا مخرجات
اسر معينه بثقافه معينه
وبجند الروز معينه بادوار زوجين معينه في
هذا الشيء فطبيعي هذا من الاشياء وانا
صغير اتعرض لها وبحكم ان والدي الاثنين هم
اطباء فكانوا مبتعدين في المانيا فاساسا
التعرض الاول كان لشيء مختلف عن السائد في
بلدي لما رجعت له فهذا على طول النقاش من
اوله كان عندي محل تساؤل طبعا هذا لعب دور
ما لعب دور في تخصص اللي اخترته بعد كليه
الطب وهو الاستشارات الاسريه والزوجيه ما
ادري لكن
في تخصصي دخلت اكثر في العلم خلف هذه
الاشياء والتاريخ ومتى بداوا كيف بدا
فلعب دور في تكوين بعض المفاهيم عندي طبعا
في مفاهيم شخصيه انا التزم فيها في حياتي
مقتنع فيها بعدين في مفاهيم اخرى اعتقد
انه مهم ومفيد جزء من مجتمعنا تكون حاضره
في مخه عاد يسويها ما يسويها هذا حق
الاصيل كل واحد ومنظومه الاخلاقيه
والقيميه بسبب اللي يناسبه بيناسب شريكه
طبعا لكن في الاخر اعتقد انه مهم جدا ما
بقول درجه الاجبار لكن مهم جدا انه يكون
عنده هذه المفاهيم الاساسيه لادوار
الجنسين داخل الاسره وكل مفهوم الاسره
لانه مفهوم الاسره يتغير بشكل كبير في
مجتمعنا بحكم تغييرات كثيره تصير وهذا
الثقافه تحتاج تكون موجوده عشان البلاد
يختار اختياراته عن وعي وليس فقط اتباع
مكان موجود حتى لو هو اتبع بعد كذا يكون
متبع برضا وليس قناعه انه هذه القناعه
الوحيده اللي موجوده يكون عارف الاختيارات
الموجوده واختار الشيء اللي يناسبه
نقدر نسمي نموذجين النموذج القديم
والنموذج الغربي اللي يمكن هو الجديد
عندنا فخلينا نسميه الاحادي والثنائي
الاحادي اللي فيه بس الرجال يصرف اللي زي
معظم
ابائنا واجدادنا يمكن الثنائي اللي هو
الزوجه يصرف
ابغاك في البدايه تشرح لي كيف انت كنت
تشوف او كيف تشوف النموذج الاحادي كيف
تقراه كمختص اوكي طيب النموذج الاحادي
التقليديه اساسا هو الاساس يعني احنا ما
احنا نقول انه هو مكان الاساس هو الاساس
نقدر نرجع تاريخيا انه نقول هو الاساس
ولحظه الثوره الزراعيه الاولى لما الانسان
تحضر وصار عنده مدن وصار عنده حضارات وترك
الصيد والتجميع اللي كان موجود قبلها في
هذه اللحظه اصبح الانسان يكون عائله وداخل
مكان معين ثابت وليس كثيره التنقل وفي هذه
اللحظه عندنا معطيات تاريخيه كثيره تبين
الحراميه في هذه العلاقه بين الجنسين
وهرميه مفهومه ومقبوله لانه في هذاك الوقت
القوه الجسديه تلعب دور كبير في الحياه
الحياه تحتاج قوه جسديه والرجل كاقوى
جسديا بيولوجيا في اغلب الاحيان اغلب
العلاقات هو الاقوى جسديا فكان هو المسيطر
وطبعا كان كان بشكل او باخر مقبول في هذاك
الوقت
التعنيف او الارهاب الجسدي برضه هذه القوه
الجسديه لم تكن فقط تمنح سلطه خارج المنزل
كانت تمنح السلطه داخل المنزل لانه لم يكن
شيء ممنوع لم يكن شيء حتى مرفوض مجتمعيا
الحقبه الزمنيه
عدت بعدين جاءت الاديان السماويه وحاولت
تقنر من هذا الشيء حتى قوانين وحقوق
وواجبات بناءع العرفة الاجتماعي اللي
موجود في هذاك الوقت واستمر هذا الشيء
فتره طويله من الزمن في العالم القديم
طبعا في ثقافات خارجه عالم القديمه اللي
ما تلتزم بالديانه السماويه الثلاثه عندها
اشياء مختلفه لكن خلينا نركز على المنطقه
هذه بحكم جزء منها
مش الزمن من اوائل الدولي لاحظ التغير في
هذا النموذج هي الدول اللي كانت داخل في
الحروب العالميه الاولى والثانيه لما كان
اغلب الرجال خرجوا للقتال وكان عندهم
اقتصادات متطوره تحتاج وجود عمل ففي هذه
اللحظه كان في تشجيع حكومي لدخول الانثى
سوق العمل وهذا اداهم لاول مره ما دخيل
حره بشكل جمعي طبعا كان في تجار وكان في
مدخل فردي لبعض الاناث لكن الان اصبح توجه
مجتمعي كامل يعني بدا من حاجه الاقتصاد
والدوله اصلا نعم بدا من حاجة اقساط دوله
بالاضافه الى التقدم التقني في الحياه
ونموذج الحياه العصريه الجديد اللي القوه
الجسديه لم تعد تلعب دور كبير فيه فالان
اصبح عندنا حاجتين اصبح في مباركه
اجتماعيه وحكوميه فلما نقول حكوميه لا
اقصد فقد الحكومه المجتمع كله التجار جزء
من المجتمع وكانوا يحتاجه هذا الشيء
المصانع جزء من المجتمع وكانت تحتاجها
المجتمع كان يحتاج وجود قوه عامله اضافيه
غير متوفره في هذاك الوقت الا في العنصر
الاناث اللي كان اغلبه في هذيك الحقبه
الزمنيه ما زال خارج سوق العمل فدخلوا
الاحتياج المجتمعي لهم بمباركه حكوميه نعم
لكن في ذات الوقت صار في اتمه الاشياء
كثيره في الحياه قلت الحاجه
للقوه الجسديه حاتم في الحياه بالعموم
وزاد شده القوانين التي تحد بشكل كبير من
القوه الجسديه داخل المنزل والاجل هذا
الاسباب الرئيسيه التي منحت النظام
الحرامي الاول قبوله بدات تتلاشى تدريجيا
وبدا السؤال يجي لماذا حنلتزم بهذا الشيء
اذا انتفت اسباب الرئيسيه في مجتمعات
خارجيه امشي عشرات السنين الى الامام
وندخل في مجتمعنا اللي احنا قاعدين نتكلم
عنه ذحين صار في التغيرات اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه مؤخرا لعبه دور في شيء مشابه
لهذا الشيء بحيث انه فيه دعم حكومي لمنح
كثير من
كثير من الحقوق الاصيله للانثى اصبحت
موجوده ومتاحه صار في حد
للقدره الذكر في الاسره على التحكم
بالاناث في هذه الاسره وصاروا جميع
المواطنين سوى امام القانون صح في بعض
الحالات ما زال فيها احتياج لراي الرجل
رغم انه حتى الحج الان تم ازاله شرط
احتياج محرم في الحج الان اشياء بسيطه
اللي باقيها منها مثلا
الموافقه على الزواج الاول واشياء زي كذا
لانها شيء صميم من الثقافه والدين
المجتمعي لكن اللي قاعد يصير انه دوله انه
الان اختيار المجتمع اول كان في مباركه
لبعض الاختيارات اللي كانت موجوده ومقبوله
في زمنها والان قاعد يتغير هذا الشيء اضف
الى ذلك برضو يعني نفس الكلام يكون اقوله
دخول اناث للسوق العمل والاتمه اللي قاعده
تصير وبضيف لها كمال سهوله
التعرض للثقافات الاخرى وحتى الثقافات
ذاتها المجتمع اصبحنا نرى حياه بعضنا
البعض وهذا يمنحنا القدره على انه نشيل
بعض الفرضيات انه هذا غير موجود في
مجتمعنا وهذا غير موجود في مجتمعنا وفتح
باب انه نناقش مع جيراننا
فلان يسوي زي كذا وهذا بدا فتح باب نقاشات
لم تكن موجوده سابقا
قبل لا نبدا ندخل في الانتقاله ودي من
منظورك
كيف تفهم وتحلل النموذج القديمه والنموذج
الاحادي انه مو كله سيء يعني بقول انه
معظم العوائل كانت مرتاحه كانت كان يشتغل
ابغى افهم انت كيف كنت تقراه اللي الاب
يصرف نموذج الهرمي هذا الا بيصرف الزوجه
ما تصرف كيف كيف كنت تشوف اعتقد النموذج
فعلا لاجواء كثيره كان هو نموذج السائد
وكان نموذج اللي يظهر ليظهر لنا انه هو
كان ناجح وناجع واستمر وهذا سبب في
استمراره اعتقد في هذيك الفتره الزمنيه
كان هذا هو المقبول مجتمعيا وكان الطرفين
عندهم توقع انه هذا هو الاساس هذه توقعاته
المتبادله لعبه دور في قبول الطرفين
للاحداث اللي قاعده تصير والواجبات اللي
قاعده تصيروا تقسيم اللي قاعد يصير ابغى
اضيف كذا انه ترى
قبل السوشيال ميديا قبل ثوره حقت وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كانت خصوصا في مجتمعنا
كان الحياه سريه بشكل كبير واحيانا كثير
احنا ما نعرف اللي يصير في بيوت الناس فما
عندنا مجال نقارن ما عندنا مجال نكتشف ما
عندنا مش هنشوف هل في نماذج اخرى موجوده
ولا لا كان هذا نموذج الوحيد
هذا كان ناجح بشكل كبير لانه في هذيك
الفتره كان فعلا بل انت ليس لها مكان كبير
في الحياه الانثى لها مكان كبير داخل
المنزل الرجل كان عنده واجبات كثيره خارج
المنزل تقتضي انه هو يمضي طويل فكان يضطر
انه الانثى تمضي وقت طويل داخل المنزل
ايضا
والوظائف كانت له فهو الذي ياتي بالمال
وكان في قبول من الطرفين انه هو له السلطه
بشكل كبير هذا القبول هو قبول مجتمعي ذو
اساس ديني اشياء كثيره جدا لكنه كان ماشي
بشكل جيد لقبول الطرفين والمجتمع كان هذا
الشيء السائد فيه والشيء المهيا له هذا
المجتمع بطريقته
اذا ما في مقارنه هذا النموذج هذا للحياه
الطبيعيه هذا الحياه الاساسيه مع زوجي سيد
البيت ويسيد الرجال وكذا وحتى انا ممكن
تتقبل يعني شويه مشاكل بسيطه نعم لانه هذه
هي الثقافه السائده عندم هذه الشيء اللي
هي متوقعاتك او انت وهي داخله وهذا متوقع
وكذكره وهو داخل لهذه العلاقه من الاساس
هذه الكيميائيه الطبيعيه اللي علاقتهم
ومتحمله كان هذا كان هو الاساس طبيعي
والبيوت تمشي على اظهار السيدات هذا هو
هذا الامثله اللي كانت تقال بس هل نعرف
قديش كانوا راضيين
يعني يمكن احنا الان لما نطالع فيهم نحس
انه كانت المراه مظلوم هل كانت مظلومه
اصلا طيب اول حاجه هل كانوا راضيين انا لا
اعتقد ان لدينا الوسائل اليوم لقياس رضا
الماضي اذا كانت موجوده بعتقد انها تكون
مليانه باي
انحيازات خلينا نشكك في طريقه قياس رضاهم
عدم رضاهم لكن الاساس بانه حتى لو لم
يكونوا راضين لم يكن سبب كافي لانهاء
العلاقه في هذاك الوقت انه حتى لو ما
كانوا راضيين معدل عدم الرضا ليس عالي
بعدين المظلوميه نسبيه احيانا كثيره
الشعور بالظلم يعتمد بشكل كبير على احساس
الانسان بما هو حق له وليس من حقه
اذا انا شعرت انه حقي سلب مني هذا شعور
بالظلم اذا لم اكن اعتقد انه حق لي من
الاساس شعور الظلم في شعور زعل ممكن يكون
لكن شعور الظلم قد يكون مختلف عن لو انا
كنت اعتقد انه هو حقلي
فاعتقد انه ليس من غير المنطقي افتراض انه
كانوا قابلين عن رضا بهذا النمط ولو كان
في بمقياس اليوم لانه دائما لما ناخذ
سياقات تاريخيه ونحكم هالماضي لازم ناخذ
في الاعتبار ما هو السياق حقها ما هو
المعتاد في هذاك الوقت ما كان الذي ما
الشيء الذي ينظر اليك خير وشيء الذي ينظر
اليك شر ما هو الشيء المقبول وغير المقبول
فهل كان واجب على هذا النموذج ان يتغير
اول ما تغيرت اول ما تغير الاقتصاد يعني
في مثانه الحرب العالميه الثانيه الثالثه
تغيير الاقتصاد فهل الحكومات احتاجت اي
دعامه لتدخلت النساء هل التغيير قاعد يجي
من فوق دائما هو الطبيعه البشريه ما كانت
حتغير نموذج كل الوحدات تتوقع انا اعتقد
التغييرات بهذه الطريقه لازم تاخذ في عين
الاعتبار نمط البلد وقوانين البلد في بعض
الدول مثلا
الديمقراطيه بشكل كامل اللي الناس
تغيراتهم تنعكس على شكل دستور البلد
وقولنا البلد فهم بذاتهم مهما الحكومه هي
اختيارهم والاشخاص الموجودين هم اختيارهم
والقرار بشكل او باخر اختيارها في بعض
الدول الاخرى ذات النظام الملكي او النظام
الامبراطوري او النظام اللي يختلف ما هو
ديمقراطي بشكل كامل صانع القرار عنده
مسؤوليه كبيره في قراءه المجتمع ما هو
جاهز له وفي ذات الوقت قراءه الوضع
الاقتصادي والشيء اللي نحتاجه في هذه
المرحله الزمنيه وفي فتره التغير او الخ
الجديده اللي جات فيها بلدنا عشرين ثلاثين
والتغيير الاقتصادي الذي نسعى له
للنمو والازدهار كان يبدو في قناعه انه في
جزء كبير من المجتمع يحتاج انه يدخل السوق
الاقتصادي وعشان يدخل سوق العمل يحتاج ان
هو يكون اكثر حريه في اخذ قراراته
ويتم المساواه ما بين جميع افراد المجتمع
من ناحيه الفرصه الوظيفيه ومساواه ما
بينهم من ناحيه الصلاحيات المتاحه لهم
قانونيا ودور الدوله في ذلك لترك السوق
يقرر نفسه بنفسه وترك المجتمع ياخذ
قراراته الدوله لم تفرض شيئا الدوله
شالت قوانين موجوده وتركت المجال للعوائل
نتحدد اللي يناسبها وفي الاخر يعني حدد
منحت الزوجين الحق فانهم يقرروا ما هو
المناسب لهم في السابق كان في قوانين تدفع
بشكل كبير احد النماذج على الاخرى بحكمه
كان مقبول عندما تغير هذا الوضع تغيرت
القوانين تبعا لذلك في رايي الشخصي ايش
باقي من وجهه نظرك في القانون شيء يتغير
حتى نصل الى المساواه المطلقه منح حكوميه
غير الازواج لانه الزواج يعني امر ديني
فيعني اتوقع انه حتى يعني اتوقع لا يمكن
تغييره اصلا غير الزواج ايش باقي انا
اعتقد انه الاشياء المتوقعه والمتمناه وان
شاء الله حيصير تحسينها هي اجرائيه وليست
قوانين القوانين مشيت دور كبير ان شاء
الله في زياده لكن حاليا لا يحضر لي مكان
في زياده لكن اللي يحضرني هو الاجراءات
تسهيلها بوضوحها
ممكن يلعب دور كبير في شعور اكثر بالام
عند الطرفين الذكر والانثى بحيث انه ما في
احد يشعر انه تغير عليه الوضع بشكل ظالم
له طبعا عمره ما كنانيه لكن العيون
الافتراض البشري ممكن يرى انه بعض التغيير
لمصلحته
بس اشعر انه وصلنا مرحله من يعني في
امريكا يقولون
انه في يعني عنصريه
داخل النظام نفسه اشهر انه الوضع عندنا ما
في شيء في النظام يعني الحقوق المكفوله
للموظف والموظفه للمواطن والمواطنه حتى
قضايا اللي فيها النفقه وكذا في شعور عام
انه دائما الشيخ مع الام يعني انه حتى في
قبائل الخلع في كذا الجو العام احس انه في
اتفاق انه فقراء الخلع في
كانه الوضع مع النساء اكثر اتتفق انا
اعتقد ان النص النظام النص خلي الممارسه
نص النظام كان بشكل كبير يطمح الى جعل
الارضيه متساويه للجميع وكل حاله فرديه
يعتمد ايش اللي صاير داخل هذه العلاقه في
تحديد القاضي
انا قد اختلف معك قليلا لانه اعتقد
اجرائيا ما زال كثير من الاشخاص اللي
يقومون بهذه الاجراءات ابناء مجتمع هم
عندهم رؤيتهم الشخصيه فكل ما زادت مساحه
حريتهم في اخذ القرارات قدرتهم على
الاجتهاد كاي انسان معين انسان عنده ثقافه
الخاصه الا ما انحيازاتنا الداخليه تلعب
دور في قراراتنا وهذا عشان كذا التقنين
قاعد يزداد وضوحا لتقليل هذه الانحيازات
الداخليه اللي انا اعتقد انها ما زالت
موجوده يعني للاسف في طبعا في تحسن الحمد
لله لكن للاسف ما زال في كثير من الشكاوي
انه القانون موجود لكن تطبيقه صعب ونعتقد
مع الوقت هذا الشيء بشكل تدريجي حيتغير ان
لم تزداد وضوح القوانين ويصير في تحديد
اكثر للاجراءات الزمن بحد ذاته كفيل انه
يغير الاشخاص وقناعاته من حيزاتهم
الداخليه جميل
حتى والله مو اخر كثير يعني اخر كم سنه
معدوده
وصلنا الى مرحله ممتازه جدا جدا يعني ايش
صار في العائله بعد كل هذا تحسينات طيب
هذه التحسينات كان فيه وقتها ايضا تغيير
اقتصادي كبير التغيير الاقتصادي خصوصا في
بعد تجاوز مرحله الطفره اللي احنا مررنا
فيها اصبح الانسان يجب ان يضع في عين
الاعتبار انه احيانا طموحاته ما تتوافق مع
مداخيله يعني جيل ابويا وابوك كان ممكن في
مرحله الطفره كانوا يفعلون اشياء معينه في
مقابل كبير والمقابل اللي ياخذونه ويمكنه
من اشياء كثيره في حياتهم هذا المقابل
اليوم احنا ممكن ناخذه بس ما يدينا
الاشياء اللي احنا نطمح لها وهذا قد يضطر
بعض الناس اما بالقبول بدرجه اقتصاديه
مختلفه عنهم كانوا يطمحون له ويتوقعونها
او انهم يحطون يدهم بيد بعض كزوج وزوجه
يوصلون للمرحله اللي هم يطمحون لها سويه
وهذه الجوله انه نروح مع بعض سويه
انا كيف اعرف انه هذا الشيء مع حينقلب في
المستقبل هذا شغله وفي هذا النقاش وهذا
الجدل ما بينهم مو انه طرفين بس ما بين
الحزبين يؤدي الى انه قد تكون الطرفين
يعيشوا على مرحله اقتصاديه تختلف انا اللي
هم ممكن يطمحون اليها وفي نفس الوقت ممكن
يفتح باب مراره في هذه العلاقه لانه لما
نطمح الى اعلى وما نقدر نوصلها عشان
قناعات موجوده داخل هذه الاسره ممكن تؤدي
الى شعور انه انا ما اخذ اللي استحقه انا
استحق اكثر وهذه يفتح باب مشاكل ومشاكل
ومشاكل ممكن يلعب دور في استقرار هذه
الاسره
بس ايش الثمن اللي قاعد تدفعه العلاقه
الزوجيه والاسره المستقبلا لما تشتغل
الزوجه بشكل مستدام يعني للزوجه في وظيفه
متطلبه بالحد الطبيعي من ثمانيه لخمسه
دائما ماذا تخسر الاسره ولا شيء لا طبعا
حيكون في تغيير انا واسميه خساره تغير
لانه هناك مكاسب والانسان وميزانه حالته
الشخصيه اللي حدد هذا الميزان سوف ينتهي
بمكتبه وخساره لكن في تغير بلا نقاش اولا
ادوار بين الزوجين حتى يتغير اذا كلهم
يمارسون نفس الدور خارج المنزل هناك توقع
كبير منهم حيث شاركوا الدور داخل المنزل
ايضا اذا الطرفين يمارسوا حقها يمارسه
ايجاد مدخول للاسره في الطرفين سوف يشعر
باحقيه في تحديد هذه المصاريف اين تصرف
وهذا برضو يلعب دور في نظره الرجل وكيف
ممكن كان يعتقد انه هو نعم وربما السفينه
وهو يحدد كل شيء يروح فين يجي والان اصبح
التفاهم شيء مصيري وشيء الزامي كونه انه
نصف المداخيل او جزء من المداخيل
جابته الانثى بنفسها بمجهودها وهذا يلعب
دور في شعوره انه من حقها هذه المصاريف
فين تروح التملك اذا هم تملكوا شيء سويه
هذا كيف حيكون نظام التملك اذا لا سمح
الله انتهت العلاقه كيف حنتقسم هذه
الاملاك هذه المصاريف اللي صرفناها سويه
هذا كله هيخلق مجموعه من الاسئله الكبيره
هذا بالاضافه الى التاثير على تركيبه
الاسره نفسها بالنمط القديم كان الرجل
يذهب يفعل كل شيء في الخارج والانثى داخل
المنزل تفعل كل شيء داخل المنزل اذا هي
ايضا خارج المنزل داخل المنزل يحتاج اعاده
تقييم
احيانا للطرفين يتشاركوا فيها احيانا
يجيبوا مساعده خارجيه سواء كانت عائليه او
سواء كانت عن طريق خدمات معينه لكن هذا
الشيء حيتغير وقبولهم لهذا التغيير مهم
جدا لانه التغيير ان حدث بدون قبول هذه
التغييرات حتطلع في بعض الشخصيات اللي
ممكن ما تكون راضيه بشكل كامل مداخل
لمشاكل وعدم استقرار في الاسره عندي عده
مشاكل تفضل بسم الله المشكله الاولى
هل يمكن اداره علاقه او منزل او مؤسسه
بوجود الحزب لما قلت عندي
بس في هذا السؤال اللي يطلع هو مو عندي
فعليا شخصيا انا اسف بس في مديرين للعلاقه
المديرين الشركه في مديرين في راسين الهرم
تنظيميا
منظومه احس انه مؤسسه لحد ما ما في مشكله
يعني انا وزوجتي خمسين خمسين رواتبنا
متساويه قارننا نتناصف المصاريف تماما
تماما تماما انا ما راح اصير زي جيل مثلا
ابائنا واجدادنا انا رجال البيت يمشي خلاص
هي دخلت في
التمثيل تدخل بالتصويت ما نخسر شيء اداريا
هو طبعا حيكون اضطرار لمرونه عاليه في
التفاهم ما بين الطرفين وتاخر في بعض
القرارات هذا ممكن تقول ايجابيا ما في
قرارات احاديث الجانب قرارات باعتباطيه
متسرعه هي موجوده لان الطرفين
في ذات الوقت هيخليه في ايه نقاشات مستمره
لم تكن موجوده طبيعه اداره هذه النقاشات
تلعب دور كبير في طبيعه العلاقه ما بين
الشخصين اذا كان احد فيهم زي الفل في كل
شيء في حياته لكن عنده اشكاليه في التواصل
اشكاليه في النقاش هنا حيظهر لن تكون
المشكله بسبب الشراكه داخل المنزل لكن
المشكله بسبب سوء القدره على النقاش لانه
في اخر الموضوع كلنا نتمنى نسمع اراء جيده
كنا نتمنى ناخذ في الاعتبار الاجل ذلك
نستشير كلنا نتمنى ناخذ في الاعتبار ان
هذه الاراء المتعدده عشان ناخذ افضل قرار
ممكن لكن
احيانا انا لازم امشي لك وانت تمشي لي في
بعض المواقف احنا نعرف بعض الايفون
والاولويات في الغابات بعض للمفترض انه
يلعب دور كبير فيها
التقدير وحسن الظن في الطرف الثاني يلعب
دور في انه بعد القارات الممكن نصل الى خط
النص كل واحد على رايه انه انا امشي لك
مره وانت تمشي لي مره انا كل اللي اتمناه
انه هذه الامور ان كانت في الاشياء
المصيريه الاساسيه يكون النقاش فيها مبكرا
قبل الالتزام الكامل في العلاقه يكون في
نقاش شهاده اساسيات الماليه فتصبح هذه
النقاط النقاشات في اشياء حياتيه ثانويه
وليست في اساسيات الحياه اللي ممكن تعتبر
خطوط حمراء للبعض لكن فعلا زي انت ما قلت
هذا التغير هذا المناصفه في صنع القرار
يحتم مرونه معينه ويحتم اتفاق على
الاساسيات من قبل الارتباط لانه وقتها راح
يكون فيه صراع ما بين الطرفين ممكن يؤدي
الى استقرار هذه الاسره ولا سمح الله
انتهاء ان النموذج القديم الصحي كان الرجل
هو صاحب الكلمه ولكن الرجل متفهم انقل
الصحي واحنا ما ندري قديش كان صحي يعني
السلطه اللي في يد الرجل هذه كم عدد
الرجال اللي كانوا يستخدموها بحكمه
وباحترام للزوجه والشركه وكل شيء وكمل
اللي كانوا يستغلوا السلطه بشكل سلبي ما
ندري انا اتمنى يعني احب اني اتمنى انه
كان معظم الناس كانوا يستخدم بشكل جيد
ولكن زي ما انت قلت
فالرجل هو عنده الكلمه الاخيره ولكن هو
يستشير زوجاتهم
هو يحترم رايهم
هو يعني يقدر مشاعرهم هو هو هو هو هو حتى
انه يعيل اكثر مما ينبغي ويحب انه يدلع
زوجته ويحب انه يعطيها اكثر من اللي هي
تبغاه وانه يراعي مشاعرها قبل ما هي وهكذا
هذا كان المده الصحي
هذا مو افضل من انه في راسين في الهرم طيب
انا حاتجنب كلمه افضل وغير افضل لكن بس
ابغى ازيد نقطه انه هذا النموذج يمكن كان
يكون مقبول للاشخاص الذين يعتقدون ان هذا
هو النموذج الاوحد
ممكن اجيال اخرى تاليه جاءت في الزمن ترى
انه هذا اختيار الرجل هو اختار ذلك فهو
الان لا يتفضل علي بكل هذا هذا اختياره
لانه هو اختار هذا الشيء فيجب عليه فعل
هذا كله وهذا يقلل من شعور الشكر والعرفان
اللي هو محفز اساسي للرجل انه يستمر في
فعل ما كان يفعله من احتواء لانه الان طيب
انت اخترته كذا يعني النظام القانون هو
النماذج كثيره في المجتمع مختلفه انت التي
انت الذي اخترت هذا النموذج انت يجب عليك
فعل ذلك يجب ان تحتويني وتحتوي رغباتي
وتلبيها بالكامل لانك انت قررت ذلك ليس
لانه هو الاساس اللي كلنا ماشيين عليه بين
اختيار
وهذا يؤدي الى انه قد لا يكون الجمال اللي
انت قاعد توصفه
حاليا كان موجود زمان جميل جدا زمان قد
لكن لا يكون بذات الجمال حاليا خصوصا اذا
الطرف الثاني يتمنى غير ذلك انه احيانا
كثيره نعم اكرمني واحترمني كل شيء لكن قد
يكون جزء من الاكرام والاحترام ترك مجال
لي ومساحه لان اكون ذاتي جنبا اليك وليس
احد المشاكل الاخرى التي قد تنجر
المراه عندها التزام مختلف تماما عن
الرجال ولا يستطيع الرجل المشاركه فيه
البث اللي هو الحمل والولاده بعد الولاده
في التربيه والعنايه والرعايه ويجب انه
اصلا من رجلكم موجوده كذا وهذا الدور الاب
مهم جدا ولكن في هذا المسؤوليه ما نقدر
احنا ندخل فيها فهذا ما يصنع فجوه تخلينا
لازم نتفاوت في الانشغال الخارجي ما تشوف
هذا تحدي
والاسلوب مهما وصل في وجهه نظري ما يغني
يعني كم اجازه الامومه وكم مجلس الولاده
وكذا بعد اضافي الا 100% انا اعتقد انه
الحل بيقدر انثى ذاتها هي التي تقرر ما
يناسبها في هذه الفتره من عمرها هل تريد
الانجاب في هذه المرحله هي تعرف تحديات
الانجاب
هل واثقه ان اشاركها لجنبها ان شاء الله
حيقوم بالدوره اللوجستي اللازم قبل واثناء
وما بعد الحمل وفي الاخر هذا اللي دفع
كثير من الاناث الى تاجيل الانجاب لفتره
معينه من الزمن حتى يستقرن في عملهن او
ينجبنا قبل انطلاق الى سوق العمل لانهم
لكن في الاخر انا اعتقد انه هذا قرار
الانثى ذاتها هي ترتب جدولها واولوياتها
وهل شريكها جاهزه لذلك ام لا ثم تاخذ اللي
يناسبها لا اعتقد انه من المناسب انه نفرض
عليه الناعم نمط معين نحن نجيبه ونقولوا
احنا بنقول احنا ما تصدق كرجال كشركائهم
نقول لهم ترى كذا وكذا وكذا لانها حق
النصيحه طبعا ولا انا حق النقاش لكن اعتقد
زي انت ما قلت الثقل الموجود والتبعات
اللي ممكن تؤثر على مسيرتها المهنيه
مستقبلا خصوصا في مجتمع زي المجتمع اللي
احنا فيه اللي الان في انطلاقه كبيره
ومنافسه عاليه في جميع الوظائف اعتقد انه
هذا القرار يجب ان يكون عندها طبعا اتفاق
الطرفين لكن عدم التوازن يخليه
الثقل الاكبر عليها فالقرار في اخره عندها
انه تبعت اكبر عليها هي وعلى الاسره ككل
بعد ذلك كان في مقطع منتشر في امريكا
لفتاه امريكيه واضح انها مسلمه هي محجبه
يعني فكانت تقول انه بشكل فظفت المقطع
عرفت المقطع اللي في بالي انت حطيته
طيب يعني هو مستفز استفزاز اللي فيه فكان
المقطع في هذا البنت اللطيفه اللي قاعد
تتكلم عن دورها كزوجه انه انا تقول انه
انا زوجه مطيعه
وخاضعه لزوجي هو الملك حقي وانا اخترته
انه يكون الملك حقي وانا حسمع كلامه بهذا
الشكل اللي ما في احد في مجتمع يتقبل الان
اني انا احس مع كلامه زي ما يبغى وانا
ماشي في الطريق وماشي في ظل وماشي وراه
وهو سيدي وانا ماشي زي ما هو يبغى حسوي
وانا مبسوطه لاني انا في طبعا جانب
الاختيار يمكن هي كانت تعززه انها ما هي
مغصوبه هل انت لما تشوف هذا المقطع
تشوف وحده
اختارت هذا الطريق وراضيه فيه وانت في مخك
وبرايك الحقيقي الحقيقي الحق مش
الدبلوماسي تشوف ان هي حتكمل حياتها راضيه
ولا تحس ان هي قاعده تقع بفخ هذا النموذج
لوحده راضيه يمكن ان يكون صحي طيب اول شيء
هذا النموذج اتكلم عنه هو باعلامي انا
متاكد اني سويته عشان تكون بس في بنات زي
كذا في بنات كثير زي كذا واعتقد هو مثال
جيد للنقاش حلو لانه هي حطت كل شيء كل شيء
اكثر طريقه
فيها مواجهه يعني ما بقول مستفزه فيها
مواجهه وتصريح ممكن وهذا مثال جيد لنقاش
هذا الشيء انا اعتقد ان هناك زوجي سيدي
على راسي وانا اسمع كلامه واسوي اللي
يبغاه لانه هو زوجي زي كذا يعني طيب جوابا
على هذا انا اعتقد انه انا مؤمن انه هناك
شريحه من البشر
عن بعض يا اخي كل واحد جاي من ثقافه
مختلفه بتجربه شخصيه مختلفه نظره الاسره
فيها كان فيها اساسيات مختلفه وكان فيها
نواقص قد تدفعنا الى انه لا احنا نبقى زي
كذا ونبحث عن شريك مختلف عن اللي شفناه في
حياتنا وهذا من حق الانسان انه يكون واضح
وصريح مع نفسه يقرر هو ايش يبغى يرتبط
بالانسان الذي يوافق هذا التوجه
هذا الفيديو حتى شاركته اظن
[موسيقى]
انا عارف وساكن تمشي في سيركل
يعني حتى انا حتى انا ما نشرته حطيته في
السيركل يعني في دائره مغلقه في تويتر
يعني بس ما نشرته على العموم لانه مستفز
فعلا وعينيا انا احاول اني ما احد يصدقني
بس والله اني حاول اني هذاك الفيديو يعني
حتى حتى انا ما تجرات اني عن شرع لانه
فعلا مستفز وحتى النساء اللي هم اختاروا
هذا نمط الحياه بشكل طبيعي
يستفزهم انهم يسمع وحده تقول زي كذا يعني
هي راضيه ومحترمه زوجها مساحته الخاصه وهو
محترمه لا تطلع وحده تقول انا تحت
كانها قربت تقول انا تحت رجل زوجي وهو
يمشي انا وراه باللي يبغاه انا اعتقد انه
الاستفزازي حاتم نابع من انه بعض الاشخاص
الذين يتبنون التوجه هذا من الذكور
يشبهون الاخرين على توجههم ويتكلموا
بطريقه فيها عن جهيه وتقليل من الاناث اذا
اختاروا طريق غير ذلك ومن الذكور اللي
اختاروا اساسا الطريقه المختلف عنهم وفي
مجتمعاتهم سواء كانت مجتمعات بعيده قديمه
ما يفرق فن
كانوا يجبروا او ما زالوا يجبروا الانثى
على هذا الشيء
فالاستفزاز نابع من انه في فرق ما بين
الطرفين في طرف يبغى شيء من حقه وفي الطرف
يبغى يفرض على الاخرين شيء اخر لانه في
الاخر المدرسه الحديثه للاسره والمشاركه
ما بين الطرفين هي اختياريه في اغلب
الاحيان لكن المدرسه الاخرى خصوصا في
السابق اللي يجي اليوم شيلها معه اليوم
يرى باجبارها على الطرف الاخر وللاسف مو
كل الناس عندهم الثقافه والوعي اللي
ياخذوا هذه النقاشات قبل الارتباط
فيتاكدوا ان الطرف الثاني موافق لتوجههم
من حق الانسان لكن ان اخت التوجهات
للاسف في نماذج كثيره تجمل الطرف الثاني
اعلن نموذج معين وهذا خلق من عدم حالات من
عدم الاستقرار يمكن لعب دور في ارتفاع
معدلات الطلاق في بلدنا
للطلاق ومهم جدا بس ما تشعر انه الان في
اجبار على النموذج الحديث ولو بضغط مجتمعي
يعني الان لو افترضنا انه في بنت دخلت في
الجامعه لانه يمكن سنه الزواج صار في
الجامعه او عنده تخرج غالبا اتوقع
وقررت الان لا تعمل ففي ضغط ترى مجتمعي
ضخم عليها حتى لو تزوجت وكان زوجها
ماخذ نموذج القديمه ويصرف عليها وكذا بس
هي ما تبغى تشتغله مرتاحه وراضيه مش
بالاجبار ولا بشيء في ضغط مجتمعي جدا عالي
عليها فما صرنا نفس الشيء انه من زمان
المجتمع كان يضغط باتجاه ولا يضغط باتجاه
هو انا ما اقدر انفي بصراحه في انه انه في
ضغط حياتي ان لم يكن من افراد ومن الحياه
ذاتها ومن المقارنات الاجتماعيه وهو من
الحياه لم يكن من افراد مجرد النظر للحياه
الاخرين او احيانا حتى الفرص لما انت تضطر
تروح لمكان معين وتحتاج مبلغ معين ليس في
ميزانيه هذه الاسره اللي يصرف عليها انسان
واحد
حتى لو من داخل الانسان على ذاته نعم هناك
ضغط بس الفرق بين الضغطين انه احد الطرفين
عنده القدره على العوده لسوق العمل
والضغط الاخر قد لا يكون الانسان عنده
القدره على الخروج من المنزل اذا لم يسمح
له بذلك تقدر تشتغل وما تشتغل بس الزوجه
المظلومه خلاص يعني محصوره
ففي فرق ما بين انه الضغط يكون حياتي
مجتمعي اطلعي وفي فرق ما بين يمكن من داخل
المنزل لزوج كلها اقعدي ليس لك الحق في
طموح وليس لك الحق في الخروج ليس لك الحق
حتى في انك ترفعين مستوى الاسره لو انت
رحتي وحتى كل راتبك المدرسه اولادك لا
لانه انا الرجل انا اللي اقرر اللي هو جزء
من مستوى معيشتها هي ايضا يعني قادر انها
ترفع حتى مستواها واسرتها واولادها بس
يعني موضوع غصبا في هذا المستوى انا ما
اقول هذا نموذج منتشر بالعكس هذا نموذج
قاعد ياخذ في الانحسار كلما تقدم الزمن كل
ما ادت الايام والسنين كل ما يقل هذا
الشيء لكن هذا لا ين وجود ايضا ولا ينفي
صراعات كثيره تجبر الانثى انها تظل في
منزلها رغم القانون يسمح لها بالخروج لكن
القوه الثقافيه العائليه ما زالت قويه في
كثير من المناطق المملكه وتخليها تشعر هي
بغض النظر سمح لها القانون ولا لا عائلتها
عندها سلطه عليها او تمنعها من ذلك هل
العوائل اللي فيها امراه عامله وهم يعني
نسبه كبيره الان وفي تسعه احنا قاعدين
يشاركوا في المصاريف بنفس نسبه ارتفاع عدد
العاملات المراه العاملات يعني انا اعتقد
جواب هذا السؤال يحتاج دراسه معينه في بعض
الدراسات ما كانت لهذا الموضوع تحديدا
كانت لي دخل الرجل في العائله فلا يمكن
قياسها رغم انه في اشياء رايت كثير
يقيسونها لكن لو نظروا في اساس البحث ذاته
ولم يكن هدفه انه انت تصرف ولا ما تصرف
وراس الهرم اللي هو الذكر في النموذج
القديم كما دخلوه وكم دخل الاسره بذلك لكن
هذا الشيء انا اعتقد ان هو بحسب اتفاق
الطرفين يصير ولا انا لا اعلم الله فما
عندك يعني قراءه لي هو ما في ارقام طبيعي
ما في ارقام لكن من قراءتي انا انا اعتقد
انه جزء كبير من الاناث يصرفون على بيوتهم
ولو جزئيا مو لازم بكامل الراتب مو لازم
في الاساسيه لكن ولو جزئيا كثير منه يفعل
ذلك هذا لا يعني انه اللي فالون كفايه هذا
لا يعني لا يفعلونه هيؤثرني من حمض صلاحيه
معينه ولا لا هذا يعتمد الطرفين مع بعض
لكنه موجود هو الاغلب لا اعلم في نموذج
الرجال والرجل مره يعملون بس الرجل متمسك
بعاداته الدينيه القبليه الاجتماعيه اللي
هو بس انه ما لم يمنعها من العمل صار هي
عندها عشره الاف وهو عنده عشره الاف بس
عشره الاف الرجال حقه البيت وعشره في
المراه حقت
المساج والشنط والجزم كذا ما ادري هل هو
محيطي ولا بس اشوفه بكثره جدا انه
ما هو ممنوع تشتغلي بس لسه ما حتصرفي فاهم
قصدي في منطقه في النص بين اليمين واليسار
مسموح انها تشتغل معها انه انا ما حمنعها
او هذا هي براحتها بس ما حخليها تصرف لان
انا رجل اصرف هذا ما تحس انه قلب ظلم على
الرجل طيب اول شيء انا اظن انه هذا الشيء
سوا باختيار فاذا احد ظلمه فهو ظالم لنفسه
بس هو اللي يقرر يحط هذا المسؤوليه والثقل
على ذاته وانا اتفق معك كثير من الذكور
يفعل ذلك عن شهامه عن رجوله عن الاصول عن
عدم اتفاق مسبق مع زوجته لكن هو قرر وضع
الضغط هذا على ذاته
وهذا فعلا ضغط كبير ضغط كبير ان هو يشوف
ان كل ريال هو يجيبه ويروح لاخر شيء هو ما
يقدر يطلع
جوال جديد لمره كل مثلا ثمانيه سنين
وزوجته تحط فلوسها في اكسسوارات حقها حقها
بشكل كامل واتفق الطرفين على ذلك لكنه
انسان وسوف يشعر بمشاعر سلبيه سواء عجبه
ولا ما عجبه وهذا ممكن ياثر على طريقه
تعاملهم مع بعض لانه عدد الطرفين في
رفاهيه والطرف الثاني في ضغط او لو في
رفاهيه ليست مقاربه للانسان الاخر هذا
اذا ما كان الطرف مقتنع تماما وان كان
مقتنع انا لا اضمن استمراره في الاقتناع
كل ما عدى الزمن كل ما زادت المصاريف كل
ما شاف ضغطه وشاف اريحيه الطرف الثاني
اجين مره اخرى انا لا الوم الطرف الثاني
لا الوم الانثى على ان هي تسوي فلوسها لكن
الانسان الذي اختار هذا الاختيار واجبر
نفسه على ذلك هو حط نفسه في موقف صعب
واتمنى كثير من الذكور ياخذ في الاعتبار
قدره الماليه على هذا النموذج ولا لا
الاستمرار ممكن يرى احيانا للاسف كثير منا
عنده قصه النظر يقول انا اقدر اسوي زي كذا
كنا مع بعض طب لو كان عندك ثلاث اطفال
الاسره تكبر مع الوقت اذا انتم اتفقتم على
ذلك وهذا يؤدي الى مصاريف اضافيه يلعب دور
كبير فيها من اللي يصرف عليهم ممكن هذه
الفجوه تزداد مع الزمن خصوصا اذا كلهم
استمروا في النمو الوظيفي وهو زادت
المصاريف داخل المنزل ففي احد الطرفين انه
نمو لا ينعكس على حياته بالعكس
حتى الفائض اللي موجود عنده قد يتحول الى
ناقص الى سالب وهذا يمكن يؤدي الى
اشكاليات داخل العائله فنتمنى كثير عن
الاعتبار يتناقشوا بشكل جدي ومبكر عشان
يمنحون الطرف الثاني الوقت للتفكير
والموافقه من عدمها في هذا النموذج الجديد
لكن لو تسمح لي بضيف شيء معين انه اذا انت
قررت انك تمشي في هذه الطريقه يا حاتم يجب
ان تاخذ في الاعتبار التاريخ الطويل بهذا
الشيء تاريخ الطويل لطبيعه علاقه الانثى
بالذكر في مجتمعنا
ايها السياق التاريخي احيانا كثير الاناث
عندهم تخوف ما بقول كلمه تخوين لكن توصل
فيه تخوف وحذر من المساهمه الماليه في
الاسره ما الومهم على كذا تاريخيا صارت في
كثير حوادث استغلال كثير حوادث يعني وصلت
المرحله مدمره للانثى ماليه
فتخوفهم متوقع وهنا يجي دورك لتقديم
الضمانات المنطقيه في رايك
احد في حاله اتفقتوا انكم تتشاركوا في
حاله محاولتك اقناعهم قبل حتى ذلك عشان
تقنعهم في الاعتبار تخوفهم المتوقع من
تكون حاضر بتقديم ضمانات معينه وش طبيعه
الضمانات هذه بناء على طريقه حياتكم لانه
اذا توقعت منها المساهمه بشكل متساوي في
هذه العلاقه انا اعتقد انه من المنطقي انك
تتوقع حتديها مستواها في هذه العلاقه يعني
احس انه متفقين انه اذا يعني ما ينفع
القديم والجديد في نفس الوقت بالضبط يعني
في نماذج الرجل العاله اللي لسه يبغى يصير
سي السيد احس يعني اللي هو عاله اصلا على
اهله ممكن زوجته ولا بنته ولا اخواته اصلا
يمكن هو اصلا مو متزوج اصلا وقاعد في
البيت متسلط على كل العيله وحتى على امه
ممكن اللي عمرها 80
هو عالم يعني
صرفت على البيت واخذت يعني
شرعيه على الاقل بسيطه ولا انت اللي يعني
خضعته وقعدت ساكت وحمد ربك ولا رحت دبرت
نفسك صح هذا حلم متفقين انه هذا صح غير
نموذج غير مشرف يعني والرجل عالم ماله
المفروض كلمه اصلا
يعني الرجل اللي ما يعني يقوم يعني يعني
فعلا خصوصا اذا هو ما شاء الله لسانه طويل
يعني فاهم يعني
انت لا منك فائده واهلك شايلينك وكمان
مسوي فيها راس الهرم لا يا عمي انت مع
نفسك كذا
صاحبها شويه لو كان يساهم جزئيا
انه جزئيه المساهمه ولو كانت مثلا والطرف
الثاني الشركه اللي هي الانثى في العلاقه
تساهم جزئيا هي ايضا هنا يجي الوضع الى
انه هذه المساهمه الجزئيه ممكن تدي جزئيه
في عمليه صنع القرار وهذا الشيء لازم
يتفقون عليهم الاثنين انه هذا هو الاغلب
الانسان العالم المتسلط التي توصفته موجود
لكن لا اعتقد انه نموذج سائد في مجتمعنا
صحيح بس حتى الظلم يعني انا احس احيانا
يسامحني بس احيانا احس
وفعلا المشكله ما في ارقام فما نقدر لا
انا اقدر اقول انت تقول بس يمكن معظم
العوائل كانت مبسوطه بس احنا نشعر ان
المره كانت مظلومه ما حتى الحين احس اني
ما ودي اقول هذا الشيء وهو مسجل
قصدي احتماليه انه هذا المنتج كان مريح
بعدين الاقتصاد تغير
فطلعت المراه سوق العمل بسبب الضغط
الاجتماعي وضغط الاقران والاقتصاد
وكان واكتشفوا لاحقا انه ما كان افضل شيء
هل في احتمال هذا السيناريو اللي يصير بعد
عشرين سنه طيب ما كان افضل شيء لايش
نتمركز حول المراه على المسيري فهي تكتشف
انه هي اولا
تعبتك اكثر فصارت تطلع من تسعه وخمسه قدام
وهذا ضغط اصلا لحاله ثم اكتشفت انه هي
عندها خلينا من جانب المراه في خدمه زوجها
لانه هذا خلينا نعتبر انه اصلا غير مطلوب
يعني هي بتصير موظفه البيت
قصدي ما في مسؤوليتين بس في موضوع الابناء
انا هذا اكثر شيء يثير التساولاتي فهي
موظف غصب عنها ودخلت معاه في قبض عقاري
لانهم عندهم مرتبين حط راتبيهم مع بعض
واخذوا 20 سنه فصارت واجب انها تكمل اصلا
فمو كان خيار لطيف حلو
فدخل في المصاريف الى الابد بعدين اكتشفت
انه هي تعبت عندها تبغى اطفال عندها حمل
عندها ولاده تبغى ثلاثه اربعه اطفال الله
اعلم فما تبغى تجيب المربعة يعني في هذا
التحدي
ثم في نظره الكلاسيكيه اللي تقول الرجل
يحقق ذاته من خلال
صعود السلم الهرم الاجتماعي فهو بيصير
رئيس الشركه وكذا بالمعدل انا ما اقول ما
في ولا مره تبغى تسوي كذا وفي النظره اللي
تقول لا المراه تبغى تحقق ذاتها بالمعدل
من خلال اعاده الاسره وكذا وتحقيق ذات
عيننا ما يعجبني انه المراه خلاص تنطوي
على نفسها لهالدرجه لانه يعني في النهايه
كل شخص فينا رجل يحتاج يحقق ذاته من خلال
انجاز ما فهي تحتاج انها تنجز فعلا يعني
وهذه مشكله بالنسبه لي فكيف تنجز بس بدون
ما تنخرط بسوق العمل للابد لمده 20 سنه
فيمكن بعد عشرين سنه تجي تقول ليش سويت كل
هذا
اذا تعدت الاختيارات نلحق نختار وحنغلط
وحنندم وممكن ناخذ اختيار الصح ونسعد كله
جاهز كله راح يصير كله ممكن لكن في النظام
السابق لم يكن هناك اختيارات كان في قبول
بالواقع وانا اعتقد القبول بالواقع ممكن
يؤدي الى الرضا لكن هذا الرضا صعب جدا انه
هو يستمر اذا تعدت الاختيارات لانه الرضا
قد لا يكون اصيل انه يكون تقبل الواقع
اكثر من هو اصيل واختيار قانع الانسان
منطقي كلامي انطقي اظن في منطقه مهمه جدا
مهما كان نموذج لاي انسان يبغى يختاره زي
ما انت تفضل تحسب سياقو اصلا وسياق المراه
وطفولته والتصورات وكذا اللي هو الرضا
يعني سواء نموذج القديمه او الجديد اي
واحد منهم يعني الرجال اللي بيقسم زوجته
تشارك في الفاهم اللي هي عندها راتبها
ويقول لها عندك راتبك لازم تشاركي معي في
المصاريف غصبا عنك ممكن يحط عليها ضغط
عظيم ونفس الرجل هذا ممكن جاره زوجته
تشتغل وهو ما قاعد يغصبها بس هي شايفه
انها تبغى تساعد وتعاون فهي من نفسها
قاعده تصرف من بطاقاتها وفلوسها وتساهم
وتحس انه الايجار تدفع نفسه كذا في نفس
البيتين هذولي نفس النتيجه النهائيه اقصد
يعني نفس الطريقه اقتصاديه بس هذا راضي
بسبب الاجبار فاظن يعني جيد نضع هذا
مهما كان الشكل خارجي اذا كان اجبار فهو
فاشل غالبا مهما كان حتى لو كان النتيجه
الملائكيه بس غصبا عن الشخص عنده كرامه
رجل او امراه يحب انه يجبر صح مهما بضيف
كمان انه
ما فيها صح وغلط هي ليست رياضيات هي مساله
قيميه واختيارات شخصيه لا تبعت مستقبليه
نعم لكنها ما زالت اختيارات شخصيه ومن
حقنا نختار اختيارات غلط لكن اذا نزعت هذا
حق الاختيار واجبرتني على شيء بغض النظر
اجبرتني على ايش غالبا حيكون في قلبي حزه
حيكون في مراره انه انا اجبرت على ذلك
وحتى اذا جاءت نتائج جميله قد لا تكون
بذات الجمال في عيني انا كما هي في عينيك
انت لانك انت اللي اجبرتني وانا سويتها
وانا ماني راضي عنها
كيف عمليه
اللي بيتزوجون اظن يعني لازم في الخطبه
على الاقل يعني مره بدري يناقشون هذا
الموضوع انا اعتقد انه وطبعا اعتمد على
المجتمع ذاته يعتمد على الاسر وطبيعتها
وثقافتها والدارج في اعرافهم لانه حتتفاجا
ان مناطق المملكه كبيره ومناطق الخليج
كبير ولا اعرف تفرق لكن اتفق معك انه هذا
مهم جدا
قبل احنا نسميه عندنا الملكه وهو عقد
القران وهو الالتزام القانوني والشرعي
لانه بعد كذا ترى في اشياء في اعراف
مختلفه عند الناس لكن قبل هذا الالتزام
القانوني الى الانسحاب منه له تبعات
قانونيه معينه هذا من اهم النقاشات
الممكنه لانه ما هي النقاشات المهمه اساسا
وعلي اساسا
قرر هذه اهم نقاشات لانها هي من اهم
الاسباب التي تنهي هذه العلاقات اذا اخذنا
في الاعتبار اسباب نهايه الزواج ما هي
العشره الاولى اعتقد بين المهمه نناقش هذه
العشره الاولى نناقش مثلا
الاخلاص ومفهوم الاخلاص وماذا يعني
الاخلاص ماذا هل هي علاقه حصريه ام غير
حصريه هل احنا البعض ولا بامكانك انك تعدد
هذا مهم جدا مره اخرى ما حيكون في صح وغلط
في اتفاق لانه قبل الارتباط ومن حق
الطرفين الانسحاب عند عدم الرضا بعد كذا
الاسباب الاقتصاديه لذلك حق التوظف حق
التنقل حق الملبس اشياء كثيره اللي هي
تعتبر الاسباب الرئيسيه لنهايه العلاقات
اعتقد انه من المنطقي بقول لازم لكن في
قلبي بقول لازم ناقشها قبل الالتزام
القانوني والشرعي نكون على الاقل تقدير
متقاربين فيها ان لم نكن متطابقين لانه كل
شيء بعد كذا هو حياتي وهو في نمط العشره
ونمط العشره لا يمكن الاتفاق عليها لفظيه
قبل الارتباط
راح نضحك على بعض لو قلنا انه المرحله
اللي ما قبل الارتباط نعاشر فيها بعضنا
البعض بشكل كافي انه نحكم على شخصيات بعض
نحاول نقرب يمكن بعض الاشياء الكبيره
حتبان لكن في اشياء الا بالعشره الا لما
نكون مع بعض تحت سقف واحد علينا
واحس انه النقاش في المبادئ مفيد يعني مو
انه هل عادي تشتغل او مو عادي هل انت
بترجع البيت يعني الرجل والمراه كل واحد
عنده تطلعات عند الاخر اشهر انه اذا كان
على المبادئ على الاقل هل انت مبدا انه
مثلا المشاركه الماليه عندك اي ولا لا
المبدا انه البيت اهم مبدا انه ادوار
للاطفال عند المراه كثير والرجل مو مطلوب
منه احس انه الكلام على المبادئ يمكن عملي
اكثر لانه يمكن نتفق يعني الحصار عدم
المنع من الدراسه والعمل احس انه شرط دارج
يعني اظن انه صار دارج في عقود الزواج
عندنا هنا في السعوديه
بس ما يحل المشكله لانه ايش الفائده انا
بلتزم في العقد بعدين بكره نختلف عن
التفاصيل لا اشتغلوا مدرس على دوام لا
دوامك مختلط لا هذا التفاصيل طيب شوفوا
وين اتفق معك ان الشروط اقدم النكاح هي
ليست بذات القوه يتخيلها الانسان ليست
ملزمه للانسان
مختلفه انا اعتقد انه احنا نمارس انه عامل
اعتذرني يعني شروط الارتباط في عقد النكاح
كخطوط حمراء اذا حدثت انا لي الحق في فسخ
هذا العقد بشكل احادي الجانب فقط غير كذا
صعب تطبيقها على ارض الواقع وما اعتقد
تلعب دور كبير في نفس
العلاقه ما بين الجلسه لكن الانسان يحطها
سواء كان ذكر او انثى لان الطرفين في ذلك
لهذا الشيء اللي هي خطوطا حمراء المعلنه
لبعضنا البعض الذي اذا تم تجاوزها انا من
حقي فسخ هذا العقد بشكل احاد الجانب دون
الاضطرار الى التبعات الخلع وما الى ذلك
لكن زي انت ما قلت
نعم القيم ومشاركه القيم المبادئ كما
ذكرتها انت مهم النقاش في القيم الاساسيه
في هذه الافكار الاساسيه لكن اعتقد
النقاشات عمليه لاول سنتين المتوقع في اول
سنتين المهم ممكن نحاول نستقرا اشياء ممكن
تصير بعد خمسه عشر سنين لكن على الاقل
تقدير اول سنتين لانه اذا اتفقنا في القيم
الاساسيه والمبادئ الاساسيه ثم على الصعيد
العملي في اول سنه سنتين ايش ممكن يصير
اعتقد هذا يحطنها في نقطه انطلاق جيده
لهذه العلاقه ويخلي المفاجات القادمه اقل
حتى ويمكن اقل في العدد حتى
هل الخجل من التواصل عشان في اول سنتين
تحس يعني ان شاء الله انه زواج لطيف وسعيد
في حاله ان شاء الله كان زواج لطيف فما
ودي اسوي يعني المسير يقول علاقه تعاقديه
وعلاقه ترحميه اني احس انها ترحميه وان هو
بيفهمني وانا بفهمه لدرجه ما نتواصل طبعا
احنا يعني انا بالنسبه لي احب هذا اصلا
المثال تعاقد الدراميه بس مش لدرجه انه
ما بدي ازعج الطرف الاخر بالتفاصيل فكيف
اتواصل بدون ما اكون كريه عرفت اللي تعال
يا زوجتي نجلس ولا هي زوجته عاليه زوجي
انا ضايقني انك سويت كذا وانا اودي انه
كذا واشوف اختي تشتغل في مدري ايش
كيف نتواصل بهذا الشكل انا اعتقد جزء كبير
من هذا التواصل هي مهارات موجوده عند
الانسان قبل حتى الارتباط وهذه من الاشياء
اللي المفروض ندرسها وندرسها كان عندنا
مهارات التواصل من مقرات الجامعه لكن
اعتقد انها تكون في ثقافتنا من ابكر من
ذلك لانه طريقه اخذنا وردنا في الكلام
طريقه تواصلنا يلعب دور كبير في تسهيل
النقاشات الصعبه نعم في اشياء احنا لازم
نسويها بطريقه معينه كمثلا اختيار الوقت
المناسب لنقاش هذا الشيء اختيار المزاج
المناسب تحضير الطرف الاخر مشاركه اذا
نبغى نشارك اجنده لهذا اللقاء عشان ما في
احد يشعر انه تم مفاجئته بشيء معين اختيار
الالفاظ بشكل محرض الانسان للهجوم ومحاوله
تقليل
العاطفيه العاليه في النقاش ومحاوله تغليب
العقل للوصول الى حل اذا كانت النيه
الوصول الى حل لكن في ذات الوقت هذا الشيء
ما هو سهل للاشخاص اللي اساسا عندهم
اشكاليه في التواصل مع كل الناس مو فقط مع
زوجهم انه هذا الاكثر للاسف يحاسب انه هم
اساسا عندهم اشكاليات تواصل واستمرت في
علاقتهم الزوجيه وبانت في الزواج لان
الزواج هو اكثر علاقه تحتاج تواصل فهي
ليست مشكله الزواج نفسه هي مشكله مهارات
التواصل عند هذا الانسان واحيانا مهر
التواصل طبعا تاخذ في الاعتبار المهارات
التحدث ومهارات الاستماع وانا اعتقد في
مجتمعنا في كثير اشخاص عندهم ضعف في
مهارات الاستماع اكثر بكثير من التحدي
وتعرف يتكلم لكن ما يعرف يسمع من الطرفين
هذا الشيء لانه لازم ناخذ في الاعتبار انه
احنا نحتاج نترجم مشاعرنا لازم نكون
جاهزين انه نسمع مشاعر الطرف الثاني
وناخذها في عين الاعتبار نوصل لارضيه
مشتركه اذا كانت نيتنا الوصول الارضيه
مشتركه وهذا ايضا اعتقد انه مهم سنه فيه
قبل ما ندخل النقاش احنا نذكر نفسنا احنا
ايش نبغى من النقاش هذا يبغى يقول لي هو
غلطان هو اسف ولا ابغى حل طبعا انه نسمع
ان الطرف الثاني اعتذر على اذا انا مهم
لكن الاستمراريه تقتضي الوصول الى حل وهذا
يلعب في دور كبير
كيف طريقه تقديم لفكرتنا انه اذا كانت
فكره غاضبه مليئه بالاتهام المباشر
احتماليه الوصول الى حل وسط تقل كل ما زاد
الهجوم كل ما زادت المشاعريه هل في
تكتيكات معينه للحوار يعني في ناس يعني
دائما اجد انه كل يعني دائما يعني احنا
الشباب في ناس يقول لك يحب يكتب مثلا اذا
عصب في ناس يقول لك نفصل يعني اعرف واحد
من الاصدقاء
كيف اقول القصه بدون ما يبين من الشخص حلو
هو اكاديمي وزوجته اكاديميه خلاص بدون
تفاصيل اكثر فلما يختلفوا
يروح كل واحد في غرفه ويكتب ورقه بالاسلوب
وورقه علميه كامله يشرحون فيها مقدمه
وفيها صدر وفيها خاتمه وكل شيء لماذا انا
زعلان وكذا وتشتغل بالنسبه لهم هل في
تكتيكات من من يعني ممارستكم تفيد في
التواصل هو بالطبع هناك تكتيكات منتشره
لكن انا دائما اميل بدل تلقين التصرف
تلقين الفكره شايف المثال اللي انت اديتني
اياه يبدو ان الطرفين اخذوا في عين
الاعتبار احتياجهم للتعبير واحتياجهم
للطرف الثاني ان هو يسمع احتياجهم لفكره
تكون متكامله عشان ما يشعر الطرف انه
انقطع في نص فكرته والكلام ما هو كان واضح
وممكن مسيء فهم وصلوا لانه هدفهم ايصال
فكرتهم وصلوا الى النموذج الخاص بهم هذا
وهم من الطرفين لحظه ارتفاع الاصوات لما
نحس انه في مشكله خلاص فالكلام لانه قد
يكون التواصل اللفظي غير فعال ما يوصلنا
اللي نبغاه ناخذ نفسنا كل واحد يروح مكان
اكتب فكرتك بشكل كامل وارسل لي اياها اكتب
لك فكرتي بشكل كامل وارسل لك اياها عشان
نضمن شعورنا ان نوصل صوتنا وانت تسمع
الفكره بشكل كامل فانا ينتفي من بالي
احتماليه ساعات ظن ويديني فرصه كمان بهدوء
اني اقرا فكرتك ممكن ارجع لها بعد ثاني
يمكن ما اقدر اقراها في اول ساعه يمكن
الساعه اللي بعدها اطلع عليها لكن هو
نموذج جيد جيد لماذا لانه اخذت في
الاعتبار ديناميكيه العلاقه نفسها هم ايش
يحتاجوا هم كشخصين ايش ممكن يقدرون عليه
عندهم مهارات كتابه جيده لكن يبدو انه لمن
يكون في انفعال عاطفي التواصل اللفظي يصبح
حق الفاعليه فبحثوا عن اللي يناسبهم وهذا
هو الاساس طبعا في اشياء منتشره اشياء
احتماليه انها تكون جاهزه عندك اكثر لكن
ناخذ حاجات قوالب جاهزه معلبه ونطبقها في
حياتنا بغض تناسبنا ولا لا اعتقد دائما
مصير الفشل مثلا تدخل تقول عشره طرق تتحدث
مع زوجي عشر تقول تحدث مع زوجتي انا اشك
ان اي منها حينجح معك لانها معلبه ولازم
تاخذ في عين الاعتبار هي ايش تحتاج انت
ايش تحتاج
وتفصلون لحاجه
في عيادتك اكيد شفت وصلوا لك ازواج بعضهم
انفصلوا بعضهم بقوا قد يكون الانفصال جيد
او سيء والبقاء جيد او سيء طبعا بس كم كان
التواصل الجيد ممكن يعالج في الناس اللي
فشلوا سواء فشلوا في البقاء او فشلوا في
الانفصال
انا اول شيء من الاشياء اللي بتعلمني جدا
انه الناس يصلوا الى البحث عن مختص في
اصعب واحلك اللحظات بعد ما ارتفعت المشاعر
وكيف اقولها اصبحت الماء مره العلاقه صار
فيها اشياء جارحه وكنت اتمنى لو يمكن بعد
الاشكاليه الاولى كان في هذا التدخل عشان
يكون ما يكون في تقريب وجهات نظر بقدر ما
هو اظهار الاحتياجات لبعضهم البعض اللي
ممكن تغيب عنهم في نقاشاتهم المباشره يكون
التعبير عنها من طرف ثالث يسال اسئله
معينه يسمعها الطرف الاول مناسب جدا
لايصال هذا الشعور
وللاسف هذا يؤدي الى انه
زي انت ما قلت كثير من العلاقات سواء
انتهت وكانت النهايه هي الخيار الغير
مرغوب فيه او استمرتك للاستمرار يمكن مصدر
اضافي للالم ما بينهم خاضع بشكل كبير هذا
الشيء لتاخر في جوده التواصل ما بين
الطرفين فلو كان هذا التواصل موجود مبكرا
في العلاقه كان يمكن ما وصلنا لمرحله
الالم اللي احنا فيها اليوم وكنا في وضع
افضل من ناحيه انقاذ العلاقه او تمكين
علاقه صحيه للطرفين فيجعل الطرفين شكلهم
افضل ومشاعرهم افضل دخل هذه العلاقه محزن
جدا محزن جدا حاتم انه احيانا كثيرا تتكلم
مع طرفين وتشوف ترى في ارضيه مشتركه تريد
توصل له حل لكن الالام تخلي حتى الارضيه
المشتركه بعد الاستقرار ما تمحي الام
الماضي انه في اخطاء ارتكبت
بس كان ممكن ينتهي بشكل افضل وطبعا في ناس
يقولون ما كان المفروض ينتهي انه مشاعرنا
وعاطفنا تغلبت علينا ووصلنا الى منطقه ما
قدرنا نتجاوزها وانتهى الموضوع لانه في
الاخر الانسان ايش يبغى استقرار ذاتي
واستقرار نفسي ما اقول يبغى سعاده لانه
السعاده شيء نطمح له باستمرار لكن اعتقد
الشيء اللي مهم لكي نثنى النفسيه
واستقرارها فاذا فقد الاستقرار في العلاقه
بطريقه مستمره من الزمن وحتى بدا شكوك عند
الطرفين باحتماليه عوده هذا الاستقرار انه
لن يعود هذا الاستقرار هنا علاقه تصبح
بالنسبه للطرفين مؤلمه ومصدر من مصادر
الصداع والالم وهذا ممكن يؤدي اما
الانفصالهم او ممكن يؤدي الى استمرارا في
علاقه ممكن مفترض انها تنتهي وتخيل لحاتم
انه هذا البيت غير المستقر من الطرفين
والمشاعر غير المستقره عند طرفين يدخل لها
طفل وطفلان وثلاثه وهذولا الاطفال يعيشوا
في هذا المنزل معتقدين انه هذا شكل
الطبيعي للاسره هذه نظره ابويا لامي وهذه
نظره امي لابويا يتكلموا على بعض هذا
الشيء الطبيعي وهذا ممكن ينسحب الى جيل
ورشيل يعني
مؤلم الطلاق ومؤلم الطلاق اللي في اطفال
اكثر اكثر واكثر يعني في دائما من النصائح
الرائجه انه لا تدخل الوالدين في المشاكل
واللي يروج هذه النصيحه هم انتم فيعني احس
انه في في
اي درجه يعني انا افهم موضوع الوالدين
صراحه لكن يعني اكيد انه كل واحد بيوقف مع
مع فريقه يعني
يجب انه ابدا ما يدخل والده في مشاكل طيب
قبل الوالدين خليني احط الاساسيات اللي
على اساسها في هذه المقوله اول حاجه احنا
نتمنى انه يكون في تكاشف امام طرف سيختفي
امام طرف في سريه تامه في النقاش معه
لدرجه انه لو تسرب هذا الكلام من هذا
الطرف تسحب رخصه ويسجد في المجتمعات
العالم الاول يعني ليس اختيار ليس تفضل
منه هذه السريه هي حق من حقوق الطرفين وفي
بعض المشاكل نتمنى انها ما توصل بقيه
افراد الاسره لانه يمكن انه تنتشر وهذا
الشيء نبغى نحمي منه والاجل هذا الشيء
ننصح انه ضعف الاعتبار انت تتكلم مع مين
عن هذه الاشياء وحذر نفسك انه اذا انت طلع
من فمك في مكان معين ترى ممكن يمشي فحضر
نفسك انه ايش الاشياء اللي انت راضيه عنها
انها تطلعها
تطلع فكر الف مره قبل ما اتكلم مع مين هذا
واحد انه سريه الموضوع الشيء الثاني كيف
تضمن وانت ما حتضمن ابدا غير منطقي الضمان
ذلك اساسا ان الطرف سوف يكون محايد خصوصا
اذا كان ابوك او امك او اخوك او اختك عمك
خالتك شخص محسوب على فريقك من الاساس
يعرفك منو انت صغير
واختيارك له لانه يعز عليك وانت تعز عليه
فكيف هذا الانسان لتعز عليه موسى يكون
عادل من وجهه نظرك انت سيكون عادل وجهه
نظر الطرف الاخر اذا حكم او كان رايه
معاكسه طرف الاخر يعني مثلا باي حال من
الاحوال انا اقدر اتخيل ان زوجتي حتكون
ابويا اذا حكم ضدها شو رايهم اذا كان رايه
انه هي تتنازل انا اعتقد صعب عليها انها
تتقبل انه شنو ابوي حكم زي كذا ولو كان
متقبله بشكل كامل الا ما فيه صوت دخلها
يطلع في اللحظات اللي هي ما هي راضيه انا
هذا التصرف وهذا يؤدي الى عدم رضا عن هذا
التدخل ممكن اذا لم يكون في اتجاه المناسب
يمكن ما هو من اول مره يمكن ثاني مره او
ثالث مره وهذا ممكن يؤدي الى ان الطرفين
كبروا الموضوع خصوصا لو كان مثلا تدخل
الطرف الاول اللي هو مثل اب او ام احد
الطرفين وقال راي معين ولم يلتزم فيها
الطرف الثاني رفضوا الطرف الثاني الان
اصبح بقول غلط لكن اصبحت الاشكاليه ليست
فقط على الزوج نفسه ممكن على اهل الزوج
وهذا يفتح باب مشاكل اضافيه اكثر واكثر
واكثر انه انه انت ما احترمتي ابوي وامي
يعني البديل
منطقي يعني
ايضا
اظن والاب يعني ممكن انا مثلا افضفض الامي
عن مشكله صارت مع زوجتي وانا
واصحى الصبح انا وزوجتي حبايبي كانت مشكله
عابره انتهت بس امي ما راح تنام طبعا تقعد
امي تفكر وتقعد تقلق وتشيلها من الامهات
كلهم يعني امي
فلما اتكلم يعني فاشعر انه كبير جدا على
الامهات والاباء وكذا يعني انه القدره على
الغفران تختلف انا عندي قدره اعلى يمكن من
امي على المغفره لزوجتي يعني انا لو عندي
مشكله ما اقدر اسامحها ثاني يوم اذا هي
غلطانه علي سامحني عادي لانها عرضتني
بطريقه مختلفه
تعرض لموقف معين هي غلطت عليه ليش وسامحها
واخذت في خطرها خصوصا لو كان هادي عاده
متكرره انا اسويها واغلبنا كبشر نميل الى
الفضفضه السلبي اكثر من الايجابيه هذا
طبعا لانه نحتاج نتكلم نفضفض في المواضيع
اللي تحيرنا تؤلمنا مزعلتنا اكثر من
مشاركه افراحنا خصوصا لاشخاص معينه يشوفوا
وقد يكون هذا العائله لو انت لاحظت الحين
النقطه الثالثه لكثير يقولونها وهي ان
المعالجه النفسي عنده المهارات يمكن يساعد
على حل مشكله اكثر من غيره بحكم تخصصه
بحكم دراسته وخبرته
النقطه الثالثه اخيره هذه لكن نقطتين
الاولى ممكن تكون في صديق صديق كتوم احنا
نعرف انه هو كتوم ممكن تكون في طرف خارج
الاوائل
ممكن يكون في شيخ المسجد اذا احنا نعرفه
ممكن يكون في
شخص معين موجود في مكتبه الحي او شخص ثقه
نثق فيه لا ليس بالضروره ان يكون هو
المعالج النفسي لكن المعالج النفسي عنده
نقطه الثالثه وهي نوع عنده مهارات علميه
معين الثاني قد يكون عنده مهارات حياتيه
قد تفوق
لكن هذا عندنا ريحيه لنمط
تعليمه اللي كان مبني على البراهين
وننتظر انه يطبق هذا علينا اكثر منه هو
يطبق علينا خبره الشخصيه وتجارب الحياتيه
واعرافه هو هل غالبا الزوجه تجيب الزوج
ولا الزوج يجيب الزوجه ولا خمسه خمسين طيب
من خبره الشخصيه هذا ليس من خبره الشخصيه
وليست ارقام الاناث عندهم معدل اعلى في حل
الاشكاليات
هذا الشيء قد يكون انا شفت كذا شفت كذا
شفت انسان فعلا ما نفسه يتكلم في هذا
الماضيه مع رجال زيه وفي انسان ليبحث انه
يتكلم مع رجل انه انت تفهمني انت رجال زيي
تفهمني فكل شيء موجود لكن انا اعتقد السبب
الاكبر ليس هذا او ذاك اعتقد السبب الاكثر
الاكبر هو صعوبه كثير من الذكور في
مجتمعاتنا وفي العالم كل بحكم التاريخ
الطويل لدور الرجل في الاسره عنده صعوبه
في التعبير اللفظي خصوصا في المواضيع ذات
الطابع النفسي او لا تتطابع الاشكاليات
الاسريه اللي لها تبعت نفسيه ما نحب نسوي
زي كذا اغلبنا مو كلنا اغلبنا ما يحب يسوي
زي كذا فبالتالي اغلبنا مو كلنا كان يبغى
يجي ويتكلم المفروض عليه ويتكلم لو بطلت
نفس اليوم ما كان جاي لكن
انا رايت ان الاغلب ما هو الكل للاسف لكن
الاغلب اللحظه من هو يكون في المكان ويشوف
اسس اللي اتفقنا عليه قبل ما نقدر نتكلم
حتى بعدين نبدا نتكلم مع بعض يحس باريحيه
في هذا المكان وبعد كده يستمر في المواظبه
على هذا الشيء ايش الاسس اعطيني كذا لمحه
عن اللي يصير في العياده اول ما نجلس مثلا
نقول انه اول حاجه انا مالي شغل صح وغلط
حلال وحرام ارائي شخصيه مواقفه شخصيه
لطبقه في حياتي انا سامر متزوج اطبقه في
حياتي ما له علاقه بكم اللي احنا نسوي هنا
منظومتكم القيميه تقدمونها لي نتكلم فيها
في الاطر اللي انتو حطيتوها لنا بدون
التعريج على مواقف انا اشوفها ايش مفروض
يصير ويصير انا لست حكم انا لست قاضي انا
مسهل للنقاش ما بين الطرفين احاول اني
اسلط الضوء على اماكن معينه ارى انه ممكن
تكون هي اماكن النقاش المفيده احاول ابعد
اماكن معينه اعتقد انه ما في جاهزيه لها
الان نضع سويه اسس للوصول الى هذه النقطه
محاوله البناء المنطقي لنقاشات معينه يغلب
عليها للاسف الطابع العاطفي مع البحث عن
اساس الطبيع العاطفي هذا من وين جاء اساسا
لماذا العاطفه عاليه في هذا الموضوع
تحديدا
في جو ما فيلو اتهام من قبل انا على الاقل
تقدير ما في العلاقه التقدير فيش الطرفين
انه هذا الانسان موجود ليس للحكم علينا
راحين امتحان هذا الانسان موجود عشان يسهل
نقاشه
نتكلم هنا تنفتح اسم حاجتها اول مره
اسمعها ليش مو لانه هي جوتها بس نقاشاتنا
الشخصيه ما كانت توصل لهذه المرحله ما كنا
نتكلم في هذا الموضوع ونتفاجئ انه في بعض
المواضيع لو وصلنا لاتفاق في حجم معينه
حلت اربع مشاكل مره واحده وصلنا لهذا
الاتفاق او على الاقل تقدير حتى لو ما
وصلنا لاتفاق ولم تتكلم كل هذه الرحله
بالنجاح عرفنا فين الخلف عرفنا فين كانت
المشكله اللي لو حتى لا سمح الله انتهت
هذه العلاقه نعرف سبب نهايه العلاقه في
منظور ان الشخصي الحقيقيه الاغلب
ما هو اتهامات شخصيه عاطفيه للطرفين وهذا
اللي يخليني للاسف احيانا حتى لما الرحله
لا تكلل بالنجاح والهدف الرئيسي وهو تقريب
وجهات النظر يمكن اجد بعض ام كل الرضا لكن
العزاء اجل بعض العزاء فان الطرفين ليس هم
اعداء دخلوا على شفا عداوه وخرجوا مختلفين
ومتحيا العلاقه لكنهم ليسوا اعداء لانهم
وصلوا الى خلاص انا فهمت نقطتك انا ماني
موافق عليها انا فاهم وجهه نظرك انا ماني
قادر اتقبلها انا اعتقد انه الحل الافضل
لنا الان هم يقولوا البعض هل الافضل لنا
انه
في طريقه لانه حاولني اصلاح هذه النقطه
وانا شايفه فين جاي وما اتخيلك تتغير وهو
يقول نفس الشيء
هذا على مرارتك يديني عزاء لانه احيانا
ليس الهدف انها انجاح او انهاء العلاقه
الهدف هو الوصول الى السلام احيانا السلام
يكون بالاستمرار وهذا هذا الشيء اللي
تحيزاتي الداخليه تخليني ابسط لما يصير
نتمنى انه متزوج يستمر متزوج يعني الا اذا
كان البقاء اسود من الطلاق بالضبط وهنا
يجي احيانا السلام في الافتراق وهذا
احيانا وللاسف منتشره قد تكون بشكل متساوي
للنجاح هو الفشل في الوصول الى اتفاق لكن
انا ما احب اسميه فشل اذا قدرت اوصل نوصل
كلنا ثلاثه مع بعض طبعا الى سلام في
النهايه انا ما اعتبر فشل اذا وصلنا
للنهايه فيها سلامه بين طرفين فيها هدوء
في المشاعر وتقبل واحترام وتبادل فامساكم
بمعروف او تفريقهم باحسان
بعد هذا الموقف دخلوا الاهالي
وهذا الطلاق اللي كان باحسان اصبح شنيع
وصار في ابناءك عن الاسف فصار في بتعرف
التدخلات وهذا وتبعني ولا معاكم أمر في
القهر انه احيانا ممكن الاهل حتى بعد
السلام هذا يعني
هذا الشيخ خصوصا اذا وصلنا النهايه ليس
النهايه بالقرار النهايه بتنسيق تفعيل هذا
القرار هذا مهم وهذا جزء من النهايه طيب
كيف حنسوي زي كذا طب ما هي التحديات
المتوقعه انا اسال طيب كيف تتوقع رده فعل
اهلك كيف توقع رده فعل اهلك ايش الاشياء
اللي ما نبغىها تصير طب كيف لو هذا متوقع
صار كيف نتعامل معه نحاول نضع خطه وحتى لو
للاسف لم نتمكن من تجنب هذا الانفجار
العائلي على الاقل تقدير اذا الطرفين
بينوا لبعض انهم التزموا بالخطه اللي احنا
حطيناها مع بعض فهم سوف يعذرون الانسان
يعذرون الشركه السابقه لانه احنا قلنا
حنسوي كذا وكذا هو فعلا سوي كذا كذا ولا
هي فعلا سوت كذا لكن يبدو انه غضب
الوالدين فاق تصوراتنا وهذا ادى الى انه
حتى المراره اللي تصير بعد كذا والتبعات
اللي تصير لو هناك لو ليس للشركات اذا
الشركات التزم طبعا بالخطه الموضوعه قال
لهم للظروف حتى هذه هي الدنيا هذول هم
الاهل او ايش نقدر نسوي غير كذا هل يعني
اذا صار هذا السيناريو هل الاهل يعرفوا
بعد الطلاق شوف انا اعتقد يعتمد على طبيعه
الاهالي والطبيعه رد الفعل المتوقع لكن
انا دائما اميل الى انه نفس القرار ما
يصير يعني نفس الاجراء القانوني ما يصير
يقرروا سويه قرارهم ثم يشارك الاهالي هذا
القرار ثم يتم تطبيق الاجراء القانوني لكن
بعض الاهالي ما يسمحوا لك تسوي زي كذا دور
كبير فاذا الطرفين مقتنعين تماما وانتهى
الموضوع ممكن بسبب هذا الشيء طبعا لا
تستثنى ايه وليست قاعده ممكن يتجاوزوا هذا
الشيء وينهون بشكل قانوني يبلغوا الاهل
الممتعه الرحله لكن انا دائما امين الى
اشراك القرار لها القرار النهائي قبل اخذه
مو عشان يغيرونه ولا يغيرونه احتراما لهم
لانه انا اعتقد انه اغلب الاهالي يتمنوا
يعرفوا هذا الشيء قبل ما يصير وليس بعد ما
يصير حيحاولوا محاولاتهم حيسالوا اسئلتهم
اذا وجدوا هدوء واستمراريه يعني تكرار في
نفس الاجابه واصرار عليها
لكن بالثقه هذا يمكن يلعب دور في تخفيف
مشاعرهم ممكن ما تروح بس تخف فكره الطلاق
احس انه لازم تكون كلمه محرمه بين الزوجين
في حاله صحيه يعني حتى في حاله المشاكل
البسيطه متى يكون الطلاق قرار يعني مستعد
انا اتفق معك تماما انه التحديد بالانفصال
التهديد بالابتعاد انتهينا كل الالفاظ
التي يعني ممكن تتطلق ذاتها كل الالفاظ
التي تعكس احتماليه نهايه العلاقه هي من
الاشياء التي تفقدها الامان تفقدها
استقرارها وتضخم المشكله مستقبل حتى لو
قالها الانسان مجازا حتى لو قالها الانسان
فقط في لحظه غضب لكنها تبدا تدريجيا بنزع
الامان في هذه العلاقه فاشعر الذكر انه
ممكن تسيبني في اي لحظه
كلها تلعب دور في تصرفاتها متاليه لذلك
فنعم هذه انا امير محرمه لكنها كلمه مؤذيه
للغايه اتمنى انه لا تستخدم اطلاقا حتى في
نقاشها لما وصلنا لمرحله نتناقشه الانفصال
نحاول ابتداء استخدام الفاظ اخرى تعكس نفس
الفكره الطرفين عارفينها لكن لانه لو
وصلنا الى مرحله
نحل فيها الموضوع اتمنى انه ما يكون هذه
الافكار وهذه الالفاظ عالقه لانه الذاكره
تسجل في بعض الالفاظ حتى لو نفس المعنى
لكن بعض الالفاظ تحمل ثقل اكبر من اخر
تكون لفظه الطلاق انا طلقتك اثقلها على
الاطلاق حتى لو الاخوه من انثى طلقني
تقيله للغايه واتمنى حتى الانسان وصل لهذه
المرحله يفكر في لفظ اخر فقط الاحتماليه
العوده عنها واللي يصير بعد كذا يصير فنعم
زي خلينا نفكر في طبيعه علاقتنا زي يمكن
هذا وقت مناسب انه ننفصل زي خلينا نناقش
فكره الانفصال لكن قد تكون اثقل الكلمات
اللي سمعت انه اشخاص تحلوا مشكله لكن ما
زالت عاضره في ذهنهم وتؤثر على امانهم هي
لفظه الطلاق الشرعيه نفسها من الطرفين
حدثت امكانيه الفكره هذه صارت قبل في
نقاشها
فمتى يكون قرار الطلاق مستعجل انا اعتقد
الاستعجال في اي قرار وليس فقط الانفصال
هو انا ناخذ قرار بدون ما نسوي الواجب
بدون ما نستهلك الخيارات بدون ما نشوف ما
هو المتاح وغير المتاح اذا اخذنا هذا
القرار بدون استهلاك هذه الفرص واستهلاك
الخيارات الموجوده فهو بطبعه مستعجل بغض
النظر ايش هو هذا القرار ففي الانفصال نعم
انا اعتقد انه قرار مستعجل اذا لم ياخذ في
الاعتبار نقاش مع مختص ونعتقد قانونا ذحين
اي شخص يقدم طلب الكتروني للطلاق يحيلونه
الى مركز اصلاح وحيتكلم مع انسان مختص
طبعا طبيعه هذا المختص بمناسبته من عدم
مناسبته طبيعه نفسيات الطرفين هذه تفرك
وتفرك بشكل كبير على المخرج هذا اللقاء
لكن في محاوله لتطبيع هذا الشيء هذا الناس
انه اذا انت قررت تنفصل بس اتكلم عن انسان
مختص اول هو طبعا توفر الدوله اعلى حدايا
هو ابتداء اتصل اتصالات على حدا وتنسيق
موعد مشترك الطرفين يكونوا فيه وبعد كذا
ممكن يكون في جلسات ثانيه هذا الشيء
المقدم قانونيا طبعا في بعض الاشخاص
بالاسم جودتهم عاليه جدا وفي بعض القصص
معتها انه هذا الانسان لم يكن مناسب وهذا
الانسان لم تكن مناسبه
وما فات فانا امير الى انه احد هذه زي
مساله مستعجل ان لم تستهلك هذه الاشياء
وانا اتمنى الانسان اذا حتى لم يحس
بالارتياح في هذا المصلحه المعين يبحث عن
شخص يناسبه يناسب ثقافته وتوجهه وطريقه
تفكير وطريقه عائلته انه ليس بالضروره
الانسان المعين لك مناسب لك
ومثل
يعني متى الطريق يكون افضل من البقاء
هذه مساله نسبيه للغايه وتلعب دور كبير
فيها مشاعر الطرفين وقدرتهم وطاقتهم على
الصبر واحتماليه توجد اطفال من عدم وجود
اطفال انه كله يلعب دور في عمليه القرض
وقرار معقد لكن دائما انا اقول بيت مستقر
للاطفال بيت مستقر
كلنا على حدا يعني بيتين مستقرين افضل
للطفل من بيت واحد مليان مشاكل والام وضرب
واهانه للطرفين يعني عدم الاستقرار داخل
المنزل اثروا على الطفل اكبر من الاثر
المحتمل للانفصال الجيد لكن الانفصال
السيء سيء زي البيت السيء عن بعض لكن
الانفصال الجيد الهادئ خير للطفل من بيت
واحد سيء ابغى اضيف ايضا كمان انه احيانا
يتاخر الارتباط يتاخر الانفصال نعتذر اذا
الانسانيه يعرف انه
الطرف اللي قدامه عنده قناعه تكونت قناعه
من طرف اللي قدامي لن يتغير
لحظه تكون هذه القناعه اساسا تعمينا من
تغيرات الظرف الثاني ان وجدت لانه لحظه
تكون هذه القناعه الطرف الثاني اي شيء جيد
يسويه حيث يسوي الاسباب اخرى واي شيء سيء
يسوي هو استمرار لقناعه اللي انا عارف
انها فيه فكانه الانسان هذا خلاص سوى خرج
من العلاقه ولو كان بداخلها فاستمراريه
لها اسباب اخرى وليست الرضا الداخلي وهذه
الاسباب قد تنتفي هذه الاسباب قد اكتشف
الانسان بعد وقت انها لا تستحق البقاء
وهذه اللحظه هو سوف يشعر متاخر ونادم على
عدم الخروج المبكر جميل
القدره الاقتصاديه للزوجه هل رفعت يعني
الان في كذا نغمه انه اور ارتفعت حاله
الطلاق لانه صار النساء في سوق الهند هل
لاحظت انت يعني ارتباط بين زياده التشريع
اللي يدعم عمل المراه مع زياده حالات
الطلاق واصل وكان كذلك هذا الشيء سيء ولا
هذا بين انه كانوا في مضغوطين في البيت
وصار يمديهم الان يعني هو ملاحظ
هو السبب ولا مجرد تزامن لكن هو ملاحظ انه
هذا الشيء قاعد يصير وابغى طيب كمان موضع
الاقتصاديه تغير القوانين وهذا يخليني انا
اصل الى اي استنتاج معين ولست وحدي في هذا
الاستنتاج انه هذا يعكس انه كثير من
العلاقات السابقه استمرت ليست لاجل جودها
العاليه لكن لقله حيله الطرف الاقل
وقله الحيله هذه تغيرت وادت الى انه
الانسان لا يجلس في علاقه مضطر اذا كان
عنده الاستقلال الاقتصادي ما حيقبل على
نفسه اشياء لا تقبل مثل الطرف الثاني ممكن
يقبل عن نفسه اشياء لا تقبل لانه ما عندي
حيله فين اروح ايش اسوي ما عندي
الاختيارات ونفس الشيء تغير القوانين تغير
القوانين والارتفاع المصاحب والمزامن في
هذا الشيء قد يستنتج منه انه الناس كانت
تحتاج تغيير في القوانين والعلاقات اللي
كانت مستمره لم تكن مستمره لجودتها
العاليه لكن لصعوبه الخروج منها قانونيه
ومع تغير الاجراءات وال شفنا هذا الارتفاع
لانه الكل كان ينتظر وهذا مشابه لحالات
موجوده في دول العالم الاخرى تغير
القوانين يتصاحب معاه ارتفاع تسهيل قوانين
الانفصال يتزامن مع ارتفاع في حالات
الانفصال والمعدلات الانفصال وهذا لا يعني
ان القرن سيء هذا لا يعني القانون دمرنا
ويدمر اسرتنا هذا يعني القانون منح مخرج
للباحثين عن مخرج منذ فتره وتم اغلاق هذا
المخرج عليهم
كنت تشوف فيديو قبل فتره يعني واحد عنده
كتاب يدعي فيه ان الرجال اصبحوا مظلومين
اسمه
كذا على قناه فكان يقول انه كان في فجوه
لصالح الرجال في في التعليم
15% فبعد التسريع والحركات النسويه
المتتاليه وكذا ما صارت صفر الفجوه صارت
لصالح النساء
17% الفجوه انعكست يعني كانت تظلم المراه
صارت هوي من رجل اكثر
فهل
لازم نمر في مرحله زي كذا تصحيحيه ولا هل
هذه مشكله يعني لازم نطلع على العكس هذا
بعدين نرجع نتعدل طيب شوف انا اعتقد انه
ما هو لازم لكنه متوقع جدا ماسك العصا من
النص ليس اي شيء اسهل وفي الغالب راح
ننتقل من الطرف الى طرف اخر الفكره هي انه
حتى الانتقال المبالغ فيه ممكن يعتبر زي
ما انت استخدم كلمه تصحيحيه لايجاد توازن
في المجتمع لان المجتمع لم يكن متوازن
والفرص لم تكن متشابهه للطرفين فهذا يعني
انه قبولهم بذات الطريقه غير عادل اذا
منحنا مثلا تعليم جيد للذكور وتعليم صعب
للاناث بعدين قلنا القبول للجميع من 90%
هذا ليس عدل لانه في واحد فرصه الحياتيه
بشكل ممنهج
اجتماعي قانوني حياتي كامل وضع افضل فمن
المتوقع ان قدرته على الوصوله 90 اعلى قد
يكون انسان في التسعين جابت 90% هذه لكنه
ليس بجوده انثى بكل الصعوبات اللي هي مرت
فيها لكن جابت 85
فاحيانا يكون اوفر كوركشن مبالغه في
التصحيح تؤدي الى انتقال
الاشكاليه الى الطرف الثاني وهذا حقيقي
وواقعي خصوصا
انا ولا مبالغه من الشباب اللي يحسوا انه
دخلوا البنات فيه في فرص الوظيفيه وكذا
طيب هو
ميه في الميه في شعور بهذا الشيء هذا
الشعور واقعي ولا غير واقعي ما يفرك لانه
اذا شعرنا فيه فهو حقيقه في اذهاننا وهذه
الحقيقه في اذهاننا حتاثر على تصرفاتنا صح
ممكن نناقش هذه الحقيقه بارقام نقول ما
زالت معدلات البطاله عند الاناث اضعاف
معدلات البطاله عند الذكور وهذا يعني لا
هم ما اخذوا الفرص اللي انت متخيلها ما هم
اكثر منكم لكن في عينيكم كذلك فانت حتى
تتصرف انه كذلك وهذا حيؤثر على قراراتك
وهذا يجب ان يؤخذ في الاعتبار هذا الشعور
لانه انا اخشى انه هذا الشعور اذا زاد
يؤدي الى تطرف من الناحيه الاخرى تخندق
الناس في مكان معين
وترفع اصوات معينه غاضبه تؤثر على اشخاص
كثير كان بالامكان احتواء هذا الشيء لحظه
تنفيذ هذا التغير كان هذا لا يعني نوقف
التغير هذا لا يحتنقل المتسارعه لكن نعلم
اكثر
ونجد اجوبه الاسئله المنتشره بطريقه مقنعه
للجميع من الشخصيات التي تصل الى هذا
الناس انه بغض النظر الحقيقه ايش هي مهم
جدا الراي العام فاذا الراي العام يرى
بشيء معين اعتقد من الذكي جدا والمفيد
والمجتمع ككل محاوله تصحيح الراي العام
اذا لم يوافق الواقع
بانه نحاول نعلم ونظهر نماذج نظهر ارقام
نصل للشريحه المستهدفه في التغيير
هل صعب عليك انه شغلك يحتك مع جانب لساني
حقيقي في بيتك ايوه طبعا يعني انت مو عندك
مطعم بعدين ترجع لزوجتك لا انت زواج زواج
زوجتك طبعا كيف هذا الشيء يسويلك تحدي في
حياتك
شوف انا ما حتكلم عن نفسي انا احاول اخليه
شويه خصوصيه لكن اتكلم بالعموم لكل
المختصين
عندهم عمق في تقييم وعلاج المشاكل بشكل
يفوق شركائهم وهذه يضعهم في مكان مما يقدم
تنازلات اكثر عنده اكثر على النهايات
وعندهم وعي اكثر على انه ايش اللي
يستاهلوا شو اللي ما يستاهل بناء على
اللي عندهم دراساتهم لكن في ذات الوقت
خليهم احيانا كثيره يظهروا بمظهر المعلمين
ينزع التوازن اللي صحي جدا للعلاقه في
التعامل في المشكله في كان فيبان كانهم
معلم وتلميذ ويكون في تلقين كثير وهو يفعل
ذلك بحسن نيه لكنه ياثر على دينميكيت
العلاقه وكيميائيه نفسها ويلعب دور كبير
في
قدرته على حل مشاكل اساسا عشان كذا
بالاشياء اللي احنا كنا يعني لما كنت
اشتغل في امريكا في حاجه اسمها
معه الطريق اللي هو يكلمني فيها في
التعامل مع مشاكل الشخصيه
دائما افضل من طريقتي انا طريقتي انا
متمحمره حولي طريقه تفكيري انحيازاتي
الداخليه تكون في اقصاها في هذا النقاش
لما انا كنت مع زوجتي او لما هي تكون انثى
وهي المختصه مع زوجها فوجود طرف ثالث يفتح
العيون وانت على طول حتفهم انت كمختص
حتنتبه لذاتك الا اذا كنت متخندق والمشكله
عميقه لكن في اغلب الاحيان حتنتبه لذاتك
وهذه من الاشياء اللي دائما ينصح فيها
للمختصين وان يكون عندهم زميل يساعده طبعا
خاضع لكل شروط السريه وخاضع لكل الخصوصيه
بقوانينهار كذا لكن
احيانا كثيره الانسان لما يكون
يعتقد انه عارف
يعمى عن الاشياء فمهم جدا انه يكون في عين
ثالثه يمكن للمختصين اكثر من غيرهم
انحياز ذاتي مدعم بالعلم
بالكتاب
ويقينيه يقينيه عاليه
سعيد والله الله يسعدك
يعني احب اني اتناقش مع الشخص اللي مو كل
افكاره زي افكارك لانه هنا يصير الاحتكاك
المفيد فعلا ولانه معظم
في مثل يقول لك كل المشاكل سوى فهم بحس
انه مو كلها طبعا بس يعني جزء كبير من
المشاكل تفهم ودائما جيد للجميع انه يفهم
على الاقل الموقف اللي هو بيتخذه سواء كان
بيتاخذ اليمين او اليسار على الاقل يقول
انه فاهم ونكون نظره كامله عن الموقف اللي
هو ماشي اكيد انه احسن من انه يمشي في
موقف هو مو فاهم طبعا كل ما نسمع بعض اكثر
كل ما نفهم بعض اكثر كل ما نكتشف قديش
احنا شبه بعض اكثر بكثير من تخيلناه لكن
بلغنا احس انه مره يعني
الله يعطيك العافيه والله سعيد بهذا
اللقاء شكرا لحضورك شكرا لك شكرا لك شكرا
لكم شكرا يا عبد الكريم العدواني في اعداد
هذه الحلقه في التصوير نايف في التحرير
ريان بكير وجميل في التسجيل الصوتي خلود
الحلبي والهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي
الانتاج ايمن خالد ورزان هيثم وشكرا للبرد
تاريخيه بهذا المكان الجميل والعريق
والمليء بروح المكان والتراب والى ان
نلقاكم والخميس المقبل باذن الله كونوا
بخير